la cession de ce soir elle va donc être
consacrés comme je l'avais dit au plan
de transformation de l'économie
française certaines et certains d'entre
vous ça peut être de quoi il retourne
puisque maintenant ça fait deux ans
qu'on en parle depuis le moment où on a
lancé ça en mars dernier le financement
participatif qui a eu lieu derrière qui
a également concerné peut-être certaines
personnes qui regardent et les rapports
qui se sont égrenées depuis en gros une
petite année
la présentation qui a été faite à
l'université d'été les sheepers et enfin
dernier événement un peu significatif en
date la présentation de l'ensemble du
plan qui a été fait à sciences po lundi
dernier voilà donc c'est sur ce sujet ça
s'est passé de ça dont je vais vous
parler ce soir et c'est sur ce point que
je vais répondre aux questions que j'ai
vu arriver grâce aux bons soins de la
trabi joël
alors la première question à laquelle je
vais répondre puisqu'il s'agit
d'élections et puisqu'il s'agit donc de
démocratie est celle qui a recueilli le
plus de voix donc je vais commencer par
celle là
celle qui a recueilli le plus de voix
c'est la question de savoir est ce que
on va appeler à voter pour quelqu'un
alors c'est pas exactement libellé comme
ça la question elle est posée de la
manière suivante c'est quel candidat
tout groupe de candidats à des candidats
pardon point e ou route de candidats à
l'élection présidentielle serait selon
vous le ou la plus susceptible de récré
la transition vers une france décarbonée
alors la réponse c'est que répondre à
cette question ça équivaut à donner une
consigne de vote pas loin je veux bien
sélective aux affaires voilà donc je ne
le ferai pas parce que je ne vais pas
donner de consigne de vote et le chic
project le mapaq musique de vote par
contre ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va
éclairer ou en tout cas essayer
d'éclairer le vote avec une interaction
comparé à voir avec les candidats et qui
va se passer de la manière suivante
nous avons actuellement demandé à toutes
les équipes de campagne des gens qui
disent vouloir être candidat d'une
dissertation
alors la dissertation c'est qu'on leur a
demandé de décrire en trois pages
comment eux ils voyaient la transition
vers une économie plus dé carbonée ou
plus des gaz et des gaz à effet de serre
y fier
et de nous le dire dans leur terme c'est
à dire qu'on va pas leur mettre une
grille on va pas leur dire parlez-nous
de talent et d'être sujet voilà on va
juste leur dire voilà dans les mots à
vous dire moi vous vous allez nous
expliquer ce que vous avez dans la tête
on va publier les lettres qu'on a reçu
le jour où le conseil constitutionnel
validera les candidatures donc le jour
où le conseil constitutionnel dit magie
les machins ou bien reçu les 500
parrainages nécessaires dont ils sont
officiellement candidats et bien pour
cette liste là on publiera les lettres
que nous avons reçues et ses lettres on
va les analyser en interne au chic
project et on publiera quinze jours
après en gros l'analyse que nous faisons
des lettres que nous avons reçues on va
essayer de faire une analyse à notre
sauce qui soit un tout petit peu plus
que ça une bonne tête sert pas une bonne
tête on en pense du bien on en pense du
mal on va essayer d'être un tout petit
peu normatif par exemple d'expliciter
les sujets dont ils ont parlé pas parler
si l'on fait le lien ou pas le lien
entre plusieurs sujets s'il ya une
cohérence globale avec etc voilà donc
c'est ça qu'on va faire qu'on regarde il
par ailleurs nous allons avoir une autre
action qui est que nous allons passer au
crible les programmes alors qu il nous
l'a sa part concédé shifter ce qu'ils
vont faire ça c'est pas directement
l'équipe du chili project mais
évidemment ça se fait en bonne
intelligence et les shifters on regarde
l'europe shifters va regarder les
programmes des candidats tels que les
candidats les proposent à leurs
électeurs donc c'est ce qui figure dans
les programmes publics et on fera un
commentaire sur les programmes en
question donc on va aussi les analyser
et diffuser et on a un partenariat média
je me souviens de redire avec kim enfin
bon
on dira un peu plus tard on a un
partenariat média pour faire part de
commentaires que voilà donc c'est ça
c'est pas une consigne de vote on laisse
chacun libre de son choix est une des
raisons pour lesquelles on fait ça c'est
tout simplement parce que en dehors de
la transition il ya tout un tas de
sujets politiques sur lesquels on
considère que nous n'avons pas de
compétence nous n'avons pas d'autorité
pour dire quoi que ce soit par exemple
un sujet qui peut te les sujets qui
touchent aux valeurs les sujets qui
touchent à la fiscalité aujourd'hui on
n'a pas tout regardé dans tous les sens
et par exemple savoir s'il faut
augmenter ou baisser les cotisations
retraite typiquement n'ont pas d'avis là
dessus donc enfin en tout cas
aujourd'hui on en a pas donc le fait
d'appeler à voter ou de dire machin
machine nous paraît être le mieux
qualifié ou la mieux qualifiée c'est
quand même pas très loin d'une consigne
de vote et encore une fois c'est quelque
chose qu'on ne peut pas faire
parce que l'on considère que ce n'est
pas absolument pas dans ce rôle mais
pour revenir sur ce que je viens de dire
il y aura quand même un éclairage de ce
que propose la classe politique de ce
que proposent les candidats et les
candidates sur
le volet sur lequel nous considérons que
nous sommes légitimes à avoir un avis
voilà pour la première question à
laquelle je réponds alors dans le
deuxième question même si ce n'est pas
la plus celle qui a reçu le plus de
soutien mais elle est dans la catégorie
donc je vais la prendre derrière c'est
est ce que les expertises du chis
project a été sollicité par certains des
candidats et certains des candidate à la
prochaine élection alors là la réponse
est nous avons été sollicités par des
candidats et des candidates
mais c'est difficile de dire si on peut
considérer qu'on sait notre expertise
qui a été sollicité ce qui est sûr ce
qui est c'est que
nous avons des demandes de contact
je vais pas faire la guerre et de porter
aujourd'hui parce que c'est assez récent
et en particulier j'ai impute ces
demandes de contact assez récente aux
quelques passages médiatiques qui ont
fait suite à la publication soit de la
bande dessinée que j'ai fait avec
christophe blain il ya eu un début à
cette occasion là soit pas beaucoup pas
beaucoup plus loin et surtout du plan de
transformation de l'économie française
pour lequel on a été enfin moi le
premier assez surpris de
l'intérêt que ça suscitait dans un
certain nombre de médias pour vous dire
le dernier truc en date c'est que l'on
va proposer de parler aux auditeurs de
fun radio s'il ya bien un endroit où on
attendait absolument parler du plan de
transformation des codes de villes
françaises c'est fun radio l otan france
culture bank audi c'est quand même un
peu plus dans le lit l'historial de la
radio fait vrai mais c'est une très
bonne nouvelle ça veut dire que en gros
on est en train d'évoquer un sujet sur
lequel ya de la tente et pas juste dans
notre propre écosystème et les gens
qu'on a l'habitude de croiser on peut
penser que ça devient quelque chose d'un
peu plus large et alors si ça devient
quelque chose d'un peu plus large mais
du coup ça intéresse les candidats il ya
un article qui a été publié dans le
monde hier ou avant-hier
qui évoquait que
une partie significative des français
considèrent que aujourd'hui le discours
de macron qui va se représenter bien
évidemment et manque de chair sur les
questions environnementales
voilà donc il ya une attente alors en
démocratie quand il ya une attente de
l'électorat nécessairement il ya de
l'intérêt de la part des candidats donc
aujourd'hui on a des gens qui sont soit
venu nous chercher soit nous on va
gentiment les chercher et ils répondent
bien mais c'est surtout la première dans
les cas de figure qui se présentent et
avec lesquels on a engagé une discussion
c'est à dire qu'ils nous demandent de
venir leur exposer ce qui adore le plan
ce qu'on fait bien volontiers je vais
réitérer quelque chose que je dis assez
souvent sur la manière dont je considère
qu'il faut gérer le dialogue avec la
classe politique en fait j'ai mis
longtemps à comprendre et ça tombe bien
la manche est un peu vieux donc j'ai le
temps pour moi j'ai mis longtemps à
comprendre que d'aller voir spontanément
des personnages politiques simplement
pour leur exposer la justesse d'un
raisonnement ça n'avait pas de portée
donc aller voir un responsable politique
en lui disant voilà le problème et voilà
comment est ce que vous devez comprendre
du problème et du coup voilà la solution
qui est logique au problème ça n'a pas
d'effet parce que outre ces deux cartes
là qu'il faut avoir dans votre jeu il
faut en avoir une troisième qui est
essentiel c'est une capacité de nuisance
s'ils n'appliquent pas la solution qui
vous paraît pertinente voilà longtemps
que vous en êtes pas là vous n'avez pas
ses capacités de nuisance
il vous écoute pas plus exactement ils
ne mettront pas en application ce que
vous leur suggérer alors la capacité de
nuisance c'est quoi c'est le fait que
leur électorat va les sanctionner ou
qu'il perde un électorat potentiel donc
c'est une des deux versions s'ils
n'appliquent pas la suggestion que vous
leur faites voilà à partir du moment où
on en est là alors là il commence à vous
écouter d'une oreille attentive et donc
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui avec le
chili project c'est que on a une
audience qui est beaucoup plus
importante que celle qu'on pouvait avoir
il ya quelques années en particulier
lors de la dernière élection
cette audience est se mesure comme je le
disais tout à l'heure à la place que
nous avons dans les médias c'est une
manière de mesurer l'audience elle se
mesure au nombre de shifter l'a toujours
pour donner un chiffre aujourd'hui on
doit avoir dépassé 15 mille shifters
pour vous donner un ordre de grandeur en
partie comme le modem ou comme peu élevé
le nombre d'adhérents c'est à dire les
gens qui payent une cotisation l'ordre
de grandeur ses 10000 1 vous voyez donc
avec 16000 shifters dont la moitié paye
d'une cotisation en gros on est un peu
dans les même ordre de grandeur que en
partie un petit ou un moyen partis
politiques donc ça veut dire que ça
commence à avoir une importance ce qu'on
représente ce que j project représente
et donc à partir du moment où ça a une
importance eh bien on devient un objet
d'intérêt on devient un objet d'un objet
de dialogue il ya un autre élément qui
probablement attire l'oeil des
politiques c'est le fait qu'aujourd'hui
on est considérés comme des
interlocuteurs avec lesquels on peut
discuter par les principales centrales
syndicales de ce pays et ça aussi ça une
valeur électorale au sens de même si il
n'y a qu'un peu moins de 10% des
salariés de ce pays qui sont syndiqués
ben 10 % de 25 millions ça fait quand
même deux millions et demi donc ça reste
une fraction non négligeable de
l'électorat et donc le fait d'être
capable de dialoguer avec ces organismes
est également quelque chose qui a de la
commandite qui incite les gens qui
briguent les suffrages à venir voir
l'avenir du club derrière ou voir ce
qu'on a dans la caboche
voilà donc cesser alors pourquoi est ce
que je vous dis tout ça parce que tout
ça pour dire que si on veut avoir de
l'influencé sur le monde politique en
fait il faut arriver au stade où c'est
pas vous qui allez les voir c'est eux
qui viennent vous chercher c'était juste
salon développement la voulais redire
avec mon nom développement ce qui tenait
autre manière de dire que nous n'allons
pas avec le plan de transformation de
l'économie française faire la cour aux
candidats on discutera bien volontiers
avec ceux qui demandent à nous voir
c'est plutôt dans ce sens là que il faut
voir les choses et les gens à qui on
essaye de faire la course est à dire les
gens avec qui on essaye de faire de la
pédagogie avec qui on essaye d'expliquer
ce que nous avons dans la cervelle qui
on essaye d'exposer les candidats
d'autres plans c'est les gens de la
société civile c'est à dire c'est vous
la racaille est en train de regarder
c'est les gens qui vous représente pour
ceux d'entre vous qui sont dans ce cas
de figure qui représentait des gens
alors qu'ils représentent des gens
justement des responsables syndicaux des
dirigeants économiques
éventuellement des dirigeants
d'organisme administratifs
et d'une certaine manière par an ce qui
les représentent mais en ce qui les
influencent le monde académique et les
gens valides voilà donc la population
qui nous intéresse avec ce plan de
transformation de l'économie française
c'est les gens que je viens de décrire
c'est la partie de la population que je
viens de décrire s'est pas d'abord les
politiques parce qu'on sait très bien
encore une fois que si on va les voir
d'abord il se passe pas grand chose il
faut convaincre une fraction
significative de leurs électeurs voilà
petite question sur le dialogue avec le
monde politique qui a
alors autres autre question qui est
posée dans la même veine c'est j'imagine
que le pcf a été envoyé à tous les
candidats ce qu'a déjà des réactions
alors le pdf n'a pas été envoyé à tous
les candidats à cause de ce que je viens
d'évoquer et en fait il n'a même pas été
envoyées tout court dans la mesure où le
livre chez odile jacob il est paru il ya
maintenant dix jours donc c'est un peu
court vous voyez ça à tout le monde ce
qui se passe par contre c'est qu'il ya
un certain nombre de personnes dans les
rues dire dans le temps et dans les
cercles des candidats qui ont
depuis un certain temps commençait à
suivre nos travaux
mais on n'a pas encore de réaction
proposition qui sont reprises
et la question du reste qu'on se pose
à ce stade c'est comment est ce qu'on
fait pour que le plan soit repris dans
son intégralité et pas juste que les
gens picore des propositions par ci par
là parce qu'à partir du moment où vous
faites un ensemble de recommandations
après jeu pendant parallèle qui vaut ce
qu'il vaut mais il est bien évident
qu'il faut les appliquer tout pour que
le plan fonctionne imaginons que vous
ayez quelqu'un qui a un organisme qui se
porte pas bien et qui à la fois un
problème à la cervelle au foie aux reins
et à l'intestin et bien il suffit pas de
dire je vais m'occuper de l'impasse que
c'est sympa puis je vais laisser des
autres en déshérence et la personne ira
bien quand même bon non si on veut
s'occuper de tout en parallèle voilà
dans notre plan c'est un peu pareil si
on veut que le plan fonctionne c'est à
dire qu'on veut effectivement avancé sur
la décarbonation de l'économie française
à la bonne vitesse il faut prendre tout
le plan on veut pas entendre la moitié
et picorer quelques mesures
dans les questions qui n'ont pas été
posées mais en fait qui est une question
en marge de celle que je viens à
laquelle je viens de répondre il ya est
ce que vous croyez donc j'ai bien poser
problème est ce que vous croyez que il
ya un candidat qui est susceptible
d'appliquer le plan là du début à la fin
alors la réponse est donc surprendre
comment ça vous avez fait un plan pour
des gens est en fait vous êtes
convaincus qu'ils vont pas l'appliquer
oui je suis convaincu qu'ils vont pas
l'appliquer ils vont pas l'appliquer ou
plus exactement il ne l'appliquerons pas
tant que le monde va rester à peu près
tranquille ce plan il est né au moment
du cabinet c'est pas un hasard il est né
au moment du coc vide parce qu'au moment
du coc vide quand il était évident que
on allait soutenir l'économie pour que
les gens conservent un emploi on aurait
aimé en tout cas moi j'aurais aimé que
ce soutien à l'économie se fasse sur des
bases différentes de l'économie qui
venait de ralentir c'est à dire qu'on
soutienne prioritairement des secteurs
décarbonés et qu'on soutienne pas trop
des secteurs très carbonées et puis que
par ailleurs on est à ce moment sorti de
notre manche le plan permettant de
reconvertir rapidement ou en tout cas de
prendre en charge les gens qui
travaillaient dans les secteurs carbone
et qui avait ralenti et que tout d'un
coup on ait de quoi les réembaucher deux
ans plus tard dans les secteurs
décarbonés qui démarrait et en fait ça
s'est passé tout simplement parce que la
feuille de route qui aurait permis de
faire ça n'existait pas donc ce qu'on
s'est dit c'est cette feuille de route
on va la faire mais du coup pour
qu'elles se rentre en pour qu'elle entre
en vigueur il faut que la condition
première qui était le choc du coc vide
soit également là je vais te dire
autrement ce plan il a malheureusement
peu de chance d'entrer en vigueur tant
qu on se reprendra pas une claque par
contre l'espoir que nous avons c'est que
le jour où on reprend une claque c'est
par une crise financière jeu pourquoi et
bien au moment où on va remettre
économie sous perfusion à ce moment là
on a une petite chance qu'on sorte notre
plan d'un tiroir et qu'on se dise bombe
à la perfusion on va organiser cette
matière de cette manière dont c'est ça
qu'il faut faire donc le le sentiment
que je viens de vous livrer d'un
sentiment personnel c'est pas le
sentiment partagé par l'ensemble du
projet qu'on n'en a pas parlé énormément
en interne mais ma conviction
personnelle c'est que ce plan ne
s'appliquera pas en période tranquille
donc malheureusement ou heureusement je
sais pas vous n'aurez pas après
l'élection un candidat élu qui aurait
dit juste avant votre truc traîne c'est
vachement bien je vais tout faire du
début à la fin je crois pas trop
peut-être s'en serait divine surprise
après tout une bonne surprise et la
diffusion du livre peut-être avoir une
bonne surprise de ce côté là mais mon
vision plus conservatrices consisterait
à dire
attendons d'avoir un nouveau coup de
tabac et c'est à ce moment là à mon avis
qu'on a plus de chance de voir ceux de
voir ce plan
examiné de très près
pour
pour réorienter ce qui se passe
alors
au peuple aux mains en presque il ya des
choses qui sont
bon après je reviendrai votre question
qui sont qui sont dans la même catégorie
et du coup je vais aller à un autre
à une autre catégorie et la catégorie en
question était croissance décroissance
donc il ya une question
qui concerne
le pdf et la croissance
effectivement j'ai plus que déclaré j'ai
écrit dans la préface du pdf de ce plan
n'est ni croissante isni décroissante
east et la personne qui pose la question
rajoute alors qu'en toute logique une
baisse conséquente des flux physiques
telles que décrites dans le plan se
matérialiserait par une diminution de la
richesse produite
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas en train de
vous cacher derrière notre petit doigt
et question complémentaire alors je vous
répondrais derrière si je ne m'en
rappelle
est-ce qu'on n'a pas un sujet pour
convaincre les entreprises et les
actionnaires etc
alors est ce que on se cache derrière
notre petit doigt et est ce que notre
plan n'est pas décroissante ista les ans
juste me cacher à la légère et passifs
peut-être arriver si je fais ça
non en fait on se cache pas derrière
notre petit doigt
parce que en tout cas je ne me cache pas
derrière mon petit doigt
ce canton dit ce plan n'est ni
croissante isni décroissante east c'est
une manière de dire il n'a pas besoin de
la croissance pour se matérialiser au
qu'il peut se matérialiser dans une
économie en contraction c'est ça qu'on
dit et par ailleurs il n'a pas de
vocation à engendrer spécifiquement de
la croissance ou de la décroissance donc
effectivement à conventions économiques
inchangées et j'insiste sur le fait que
c'est la convention économique inchangée
il engendrerait une contraction du pib
c'est tout à fait vrai peut très bien
décider de changer la convention
économique peut très bien décider de
rentrer dans le pib lecture qu'on
respire bon puis voilà donc à ce moment
la nature nous un service qu'on va jb on
peut très bien rentrés dans le pib jeu
pourquoi la base du stress on a un sujet
pib qu'on peut qui est un sujet
conventionnel un jour à peine
aujourd'hui au moment où le pib a été
créée ils étaient censés compter
essentiellement des objets je vous
rappelle que la comptabilité nationale
est le pib sa date d'avant l'apparition
d' économie de services moment où sont
arrivés les services on a déjà eu un peu
plus de mal à savoir comment est-ce
qu'on valorise une heure d'enseignement
est ce que vous le valoriser à ce que la
personne qui reçoit l'heure
d'enseignement on va pouvoir en faire
s'il fait une licorne cheikh ahmar ont
ensuite y gagnent des milliards ou
est-ce que vous la valoriser au salaire
de l'enseignant mal typiquement ce genre
de convention change totalement le pib
vous avez aujourd'hui j'ai fait un petit
calcul l'autre jour à peu près 100
millions de produits qui sont
disponibles à la vente et si vous
considérez que une personne travaille
normalement c'est-à-dire 35 heures par
semaine et plus pas de bêtises 46
semaines dans l'année eh bien vous vous
rendez compte que avec lady
statisticiens que nous avons à l'insee
pour déflatés le prix des produits et là
je parle juste des produits je pense
même pas des services eh bien vous avez
nettement moins d'une seconde par
produit à des flatteurs qu'est ce que
c'est que la déflation c'est la
correction de l'inflation pour ceux qui
sont pas familiers avec ça la correction
de l'inflation c'est
j'achète ce vers une année donnée en
euros et puis l'année prochaine je
l'achète 1,05 euro mais sauf que j'ai
une inscription sur le vert bon alors
est ce que c'est le maître vert ou bien
est-ce que c'est pas le même verre parce
que l'inscription de sucer le début de
la méthode à civile pour apprendre le
mandarin bon ben vous voyez c'est
compliqué de répondre à la question
si c'est pas le même verre c'est pas de
l'inflation donc en fait vous considérer
qu'on a produit pour 1,5 euro et pas
pour un euro mais si c'est le même verre
qu'on vend plus cher
alors qu'on devrait pas eh bien on va
pas compter le vert pour 1,5 euro on va
dire il ya eu 5 % d'inflation et je le
comte point nos ce mécanisme s'appelle
la correction de l'inflation et bien
aujourd'hui nous avons 100 millions de
produits sur lesquels il faut appliquer
ce mécanisme vous comprenez bien qu'en
toute bonne heure on ne fait pas donc
déjà savoir aujourd'hui ce que conclut
pib c'est compliqué dans les services
s'est encore plus compliqué donc
j'insiste sur le fait qu'à conventions
économiques inchangées absolument le pdf
est récessif le dire je vais le dire
comme ça mais c'est pas son objet est
donc on peut très bien en à côté dit
autrement c'est un débat de savoir si
notre truc j'ai envie de la croissance
ou de la décroissance c'est juste pas
notre débat
là où ça va devenir votre débat c'est
que si la convention inchangé et si on
ne change pas la convention
effectivement le pdf est récessif à ce
moment comment est-ce qu'on gère les
problèmes qu'ils sont associés alors les
problèmes qui sont associés il y en a on
va dire essentiellement deux il ya un
problème sur les revenus des individus
mais dans la mesure où nous on prône la
sobriété si vous avez à la fois un
revenu qui baisse de 30% et des charges
qui baisse de 30% au niveau d'un
individu c'est pas nécessairement un
problème aujourd'hui vous avez déjà des
gens alors ils sont certes minoritaire
mais quand même vous avez déjà des gens
qui font un choix de vie délibérée de
baisser leurs revenus en même temps
qu'ils passent leur charge par exemple
des gens qui quittent la ville pour
aller se mettre dans une zone b1 cire
froide il sait pas jusqu'où ils
continuent à bosser dans la ville et
prennent leur bagnole juste faire tout
autre chose ils vont se mettent à faire
de la menuiserie la ferronnerie
m viticulteur qu'est ce que c'est et
world loire de transats sur la plage et
à ce moment leurs choix de vie c'est de
baisser leurs revenus baisser leurs
charges et vivre dans un cadre qui est
différent et l'équation que mal leur
convient voilà
ça nous va bien vous voyez bien que là
on est dans un exercice dans lequel une
s'accommode d'une baisse de leurs
revenus parce qu'ils ont piloté leur
destin c'est à dire qu'on leur a pas dit
et revenus ont baissé et puis on ne
demande pas qu'on a dit et puis ce que
tu as quand même on va te laisser des
désirs inchangé évidemment tu pourras
plus les satisfaire parce que ça très
difficile à gérer on est dans un
contexte dans lequel on va susciter chez
eux du désir pour une situation dans
laquelle ils n'ont plus besoin d'autant
de temps voilà ce qui est très différent
donc ça va poser ce problème la très
large échelle c'est très clair si on
s'intéresse à la question directe de
l'économie et le deuxième problème à
large échelle que ça va poser c'est
évidemment l'équilibré des finances
publiques puisque aujourd'hui
l'essentiel de la fiscalité c'est des
impôts de flux c'est à dire que c'est
des impôts qui sont prélevés sur une
fraction du pib les charges sociales qui
sont prélevés sur des revenus salaires
c'est une fraction du pib la tva c'est
une fraction du pib l'impôt sur les
sociétés l'impôt sur le revenu tout ça
c'est des fractions du pib les impôts
qui ne sont pas dépendants du pib mais
qui sont dépendants de valeur de stock
vous en avait quelques-uns vous avez la
taxe sur les appels à des tensions
téléviseur sans ça dépend pas du pays
vers un téléviseur payer la taxe il faut
cher il vaut pas cher
les impôts fonciers sont pas dépendants
du pib vous avez un patrimoine foncier
et à ce moment vous payez des impôts
fonciers et ils ne sont pas liées à ce
que vous avez gagné dans l'année les
indépendants voilà donc vous avez
quelques impôts de stock les autres sont
des impôts de flux et donc la difficulté
qui va naître dans un monde dans lequel
le pib se contracte les recettes
fiscales se contracte et donc il ya un
sujet de qu'est ce qu'on fait au niveau
de la dépense publique voilà ça c'est un
problème alors c'est pas un problème
sans solution nécessairement par contre
c'est aujourd'hui un problème non
abordées donc là on en revient à ce que
j'ai tout à l'heure sur mon plan de
transformation de l'école afin par le
mien plan de transformation de
l'économie française à partir du moment
où il n'existait pas on ne pouvait pas
le mettre en oeuvre là c'est exactement
pareil la réflexion académique et
aujourd'hui la quantité de jus de
cerveau qui est investi dans les deux
problèmes que je viens d'évoquer est
proche de zéro donc c'est normal que ce
soient des problèmes qui nous fasse peur
il ya au moins une très bonne raison
pour qu'il nous fasse peur c'est qu'on a
juste j'avais regardé ce qu'on pouvait
faire jamais regarder ça de manière
sérieuse il ya quelques personnes de ci
de là à qui de temps en temps et cei le
voilà mais on n'a pas les bataillons
j'ai envie de dire que cervelle qu'on a
dans l'économie conventionnel dans la
gestion conventionnel que nous avons
aujourd'hui investi dans la façon dont
on peut aborder ces problèmes et il
s'agit pas juste de gestion il s'agit de
sociologie cette typologie etc et
aujourd'hui
toutes les disciplines qui devrait
concourir à réfléchir à ces problèmes
aujourd'hui malheureusement ne sont pas
mobilisés il n'y a pas d'éléments que le
premier intéressé qui est chic et de
l'état ne finance pas de recherche par
exemple sur ces questions là ce qui est
de mon point de vue dommage parce que on
est en train de se priver de quelque
chose qui va être très précieux et dont
on va avoir besoin de toutes façons
puisque vous connaissez mon discours de
toute façon les ressources se contracte
et donc de toute façon on aura à faire
avec moins là dans le pdf vous propose
de le piloter et on pense que c'est
beaucoup plus confortable de le piloter
que de le subir
voilà
indépendamment de la plaque sur le petit
doigt donc le btf ne vis pas en tant que
telle la croissance ou la décroissance à
la différence de beaucoup de programmes
électoraux et de plan économique on dit
d'abord il faut viser la croissance puis
ensuite on verra ce qu'on en fait et
deuxième chose aujourd'hui il reste des
domaines dont explorer qui sont les deux
questions essentielles que je viens de
poser c'est à dire comment est ce qu'on
adapte nos systèmes de gestion et nos
conventions économiques à ce contexte
nouveau qui n'existe qu'il n'ait jamais
existé depuis qu'on a deux comptabilités
nationales à la comptabilité nationale
décroissance m'a jamais fait et qu'il a
qui n'a jamais fermé quasiment jamais
existé depuis qu'honda la comptabilité
peu court puisque l'humanité a
globalement été en expansion
depuis dimanche
est-ce que les gens qui freine c'est les
actionnaires alors oui non ça dépend
desquels toute entreprise même et y
compris car 24
et un projet de conquête donc d'une
certaine mesure un projet de croissance
le jeu me rassure le virus du copine ne
passe pas par les réseaux et donc donc
le veut dire plus et
le donc des actionnaires dans des
entreprises ils sont rarement ravis que
l'entreprise dit je vais baisser mon
chiffre d'affaires je vais baisser les
revenus mais il n'ya pas que les
actionnaires qui sont pas ravis en
général les gens qui travaillent dans
l'entreprise son paradis donc plus du
tout donc dès qu'il s'agit de contracter
l'activité d'une entreprise vous allez
rarement trouvé les salariés qui vont
manifester défiler dans la rue en disant
ouais on est dans un truc qui est
dégueulasse
j'avais ça existe parce a donc dans les
gens qui vont s'opposer à ce que ondées
carbone l'économie ça doit pas faire les
affaires l'entreprise dans laquelle ils
sont certes vous allez trouver des
actionnaires c'est absolument certain
mais pas que vous allez trouver les
salariés et en ce qu'il représente les
salariés et aux visions besoins des
salariés plus exactement et en ce qu'ils
doivent prendre leurs instructions des
actionnaires évidemment trouver les
dirigeants
qui quelquefois sont si les actionnaires
donc le l'équation est un tout petit peu
plus complexe que ça et vous remarquerez
que quand il s'agit de défendre une
branche professionnelle quelles qu'en
soient les raisons bonnes ou mauvaises
c'est rare que les salariés et les
actionnaires on va dire s'opposent s'il
s'agit de défendre
l'activité en tant que tel
tout le monde se serre les coudes c'est
pour les raisons que je viens d'évoquer
si on est un peu plus spécifique dans
les actionnaires vous avez les
actionnaires en direct qui vous avez ce
qu'on appelle les investisseurs moi par
exemple je suis un des actionnaires de
44 mais je ne suis pas investisseurs mon
métier c'est pas de mettre mon argent
dans d'autres entreprises du nord-est de
l'attique personnel j'ai pas de péage
pendant la rédaction rien de tout ça
tout simplement parce que j'ai jamais
compris la manière dont vous pouvez
naviguer dans cet univers-là dirait pas
mais donc pas une affaire dont elle est
la base c'est juste une affaire que
j'aime pas les trucs que je comprends
pas donc le
les investisseurs eux ils ont une
logique qui est un peu différente ils
vont se dire si dans cette affaire là il
ya plus à gagner qu'à perdre moi ça me
va bien j'ai pas de problème alors quels
sont les secteurs qui souffrent dans une
politique de décarbonation c'est les
secteurs de biens de consommation du
reste vous êtes parce qu'on va devoir
attendre donc on va consommer moins donc
on va devoir acheter moins de téléphones
moins de vêtements moins de 10 ans dont
une prise électrique - elle table - deux
chaises etc faire durer tout ça a pris
longtemps et donc les secteurs qui nous
fournissent les biens de consommation a
priori ils vont moins bien par contre
vous avez énormément de choses à changer
dans les infrastructures vous devez
changer les infrastructures de transport
vous devez changer vous devez changer
les infrastructures énergétiques vous
devez et cetera donc là dans ce domaine
là vous devez changer les bâtiments qui
est aussi des infrastructures donc dans
le domaine des infrastructures là vous
avez plutôt des trucs intéressants à
faire
et enfin vous avez un
certain secteur des biens de
consommation qui vont également
bénéficier par exemple les gens qui
fabriquent des vélos normalement il
devrait se porter lui
aujourd'hui les actionnaires
ma perception à moi c'est que
effectivement si l'économie au sens du
pib doit se contracter globalement
permis mais aussi étonnant que ça puisse
vous paraître le monde financier on
n'est pas du tout persuadé qu' ils sont
totalement persuadé qu'on va avoir la
croissance verte donc le grand paradoxe
que vous allez peut-être découvrir
maintenant c'est que globalement le
monde financier n'est pas du tout
hostile à la décarbonation pas du tout
parce que ils sont intimement persuadés
que globalement ils vont gagner de
l'argent
ce qui se discute encore une fois en
tout cas ils sont ils sont pas
fondamentalement hostile
fondamentalement hostile quand on voit
dans le monde économique les gens qui
sont fondamentalement hostile encore une
fois c'est des gens qui ont bien
identifié que l'activité dans laquelle
ils étaient eux allait être une activité
perdante c'est la raison pour laquelle
d'un plan de transformation de
l'économie française on a séparé le
problème en deux on a dit qu'on parlait
pas d'argent donc ce que deviennent les
actionnaires pour moi c'est pas notre
problème est du reste à titre personnel
ne s'est pas le chiffre équipes 1 moi
j'ai toujours dit que si l'actionnaire
père c'est juste pas mon problème il n'a
jamais pour ceux d'entre vous qui ont
éventuellement de l'assurance vie ce qui
n'est pas mon cas que j'ai dû lutter on
vous fait signer des tas de petites
phrases en minuscule dans lequel il est
écrit fait gaffe investir comporte des
risques faites attention vous n'êtes pas
sûr de récupérer le reste c'est donc
jamais l'actionnaire n'a eu la garantie
de récupérer son argent et si j'ai un
bon conseil à donner à tous les gens qui
me regardent ne comptez jamais sur votre
épargne en actions comme sur quelque
chose qui est garanti d'accord on fait
pas ça
vous pouvez en perdre tout ou partie
voilà ça fait partie du deal à partir du
moment où c'est des actions
donc ce que devient l'actionnaire il a
investi 6 à ses risques et périls ce que
devient le salarié c'est très différent
donc dans le plan de transformation de
l'économie française ce qui nous importe
vraiment c'est comment on déplace
l'emploi sans que les gens le perdre
alors déplacé l'emploi sans que les gens
le perde ça veut dire que l'on doit
gérer correctement les flux d'entrée
faut que les gens qui rentrent dans
l'emploi aille prioritairement
travailler dans des secteurs qui sont
utiles il ya évidemment à gérer
naturellement un flux de sortie donc sur
30 ans une partie des gens dont on n'en
a plus besoin au sens devant opérer dans
un secteur donné il y en a une partie
ils vont s'en aller naturellement
s'appelle la retraite donc
n'a pas besoin d'occuper plus que ça il
faut juste à temps qu'ils partent à la
retraite par contre vous avez une partie
des gens qui vont devoir changer de
métier parce qu'ils sont pas là et vous
avez même mieux que ça une partie des
gens qui vont devoir rentrer dans un
secteur qui va pourtant s'affaiblir
parce que même si le secteur s'affaiblit
il va quand même en restait quelque
chose et donc il faut quand même rester
lui il faut pas qu'ils du sang neuf qui
rentre dans le secteur puis le secteur
va devoir changer
donc à ce moment vous avez des
déplacements à opérer sur l'emploi et
c'est des problèmes très compliqué les
déplacements ça veut dire que si vous
changez d'emploi souvent vous changer
d'entreprise donc vous couper d'un
réseau dans lequel vous avez souvent des
liens affectifs les collègues qui
peuvent pas s'encadrer heureusement
c'est par le lot commun la majeure
partie des entreprises et des
administrations
vous avez quand même quelques personnes
avec qui vous vous entendez bien voilà
si vous changez d'emploi en changeant de
lieu d'emploi c'est compliqué c'est
compliqué si vous devez été ménagé voilà
donc il ya un prix à payer j'ai envie de
dire et affectif aprilia aprilia prix
effectif biologique à payer dans ce
genre de choses et
ça se fait mais
il faut mettre en place un dispositif
qui aident à ce que ce genre de choses
se fassent donc ça a été une de nos
préoccupations importantes au sein du
plan de transformation de l'économie
française on a initié ce chantier là on
est loin d'être au bout encore une fois
comme comme comme je le lis plusieurs
fois il a fallu des siècles pour
perfectionner le système fossiles dans
lequel on est donc ce n'est pas en deux
ans et même si on a été nombreux qu'eux
on a conceptualisé tout ce qu'il fallait
détricoter donc on est clairement au
début de l'histoire
mais sur la question de l'emploi on a
clairement identifié encore une fois que
c'était un sujet majeur et j'insiste
comme c'est un sujet majeur c'est un
sujet potentiel de résistance à mon avis
plus forte que celle qui vient des
actionnaires quand il s'agit de
transitionner à large échelle
les actionnaires résiste mais je pense
que les a juste titre les gens qui ont
peur pour leur club ils résistent encore
plus
alors
c'est d'aller rigolote seul à prendre au
passage à choisir entre deux maux
continue à une future présidente de la
personne qui a posé la question a mis un
peu entre parenthèses à un une deux
affectueux mais pas de voeux entre
parenthèses président
s'est arrêté en cours de route
des croissants et anti nucléaires ou
favorables à la construction de nouveaux
repères mais qui garde la croissance en
vertu cardinale et baril vaut mieux
ni l'un ni l'autre
si on veut la croissance en vertu
cardinale
de toute façon ce que je pense c'est
qu'on ne l'aura pas pour reprendre
ce que je disais tout à l'heure sur la
contrainte de ressources en fait si vous
regardez je vais en revenir à ma
définition du pib si vous regardez bien
comment évolue le pib que je pourrai
qualifié de vrai c'est à dire la
production industrielle et les biens et
services matériels en europe depuis 2007
ça n'a pas augmenté donc ce qui a
augmenté 7 pb du pib nominal la façon
dont on compte par contre le pib vrai
des mètres carrés construits layton
qu'on charge dans les camions etc non
seulement ça n'a pas augmenté mais dans
beaucoup de pays d'europe c'est
rabaisser pourquoi est-ce que ça a
baissé tout simplement parce que
l'énergie disponible qui rentre en
europe il a baissé depuis 2007 pour des
contraintes géologiques ça n'a rien à
voir avec le climat et du coup le nombre
de machines qu'on peut faire travailler
baisse et du coup la production baisse
alors il ya un peu d'efficacité
énergétique qui compense est par
ailleurs dans la façon dont on compte le
pib ya les artefacts que j'évoquais tout
à l'heure qui compense il ya des
produits qui sont mal déflatés des
services qui sont mal déflatés et de
l'inflation d'actifs qui engendre des
produits qui sont comptés au nominal par
exemple les crédits bancaires sans
compter au nominal à la production
bancaire est contée au nominal alors
même que si ces ralliements teint si
c'est pour financer un marché immobilier
dans le prix augmente ça fait pas plus
de mètres carrés disponibles donc vous
avez en europe depuis 2007 ce que je dis
moi c'est que le pib vrai il arrêter
d'augmenter voire même il est en légère
érosion ce qui veut dire que mon pari
personnel c'est que même si il le
voulait le ou la prochaine président de
ne trouvera pas
la croissance sur son chemin le plus
vraisemblable alors il va trouver un
petit coup de rebond de presque au vide
mais en évolution structurelle c'est
pour ça qu'il va trouver donc est ce
qu'il vaut mieux un président pro
croissance ben non parce que ce
président pro croissance il va créer de
la désillusion
sur la partie sur cette partie là et la
désillusion est un poison quand elle est
trop forte pour l'événement principe est
ce que il faut un président anti
nucléaires ou une présidente
antinucléaires pas plus mais vous
remarquerez que sur ce sujet là le la
nature du débat est en train de changer
c'est à dire qu'on est en train de
rentrer dans un débat qui est plus
technique est ce qu'il faut faire des
réacteurs comme ceux ci comme cela
est-ce qu'il faut prolonger pas
prolonger est-ce qu'il faut réparer pas
réparé comment est-ce qu'on s'organise
si on a un truc qu'on doit changer
et qui me paraît être le niveau sein du
débat parce que le niveau sein du débat
c'est de regarder les chiffres et les
fêtes et de par les actions sur la base
de faits
et pas uniquement de ressenti quand ils
sont pas en adéquation avec les faits
si on a quelqu'un d'antinucléaires en
fait dans ma vision du monde où ce sont
les machines qui produisent et bien ça
comme on sera pas capable de remplacer à
la bonne vitesse on doit du reste rien
que chez les allemands qui est pourtant
riche et les loisirs ne manquait
pourtant moins de nucléaire que nous là
le nucléaire uniquement par des
renouvelables et du stockage et bien
on court le risque d'avoir des défauts
d'approvisionnement en énergie donc de
ne pas avoir assez d'électricité d'avoir
de temps en temps des coupures des
blacks arles des rationnements etc et ça
ça va contracter à cause du lien énergie
économie le système économique plus vite
et peut-être plus vite qu'il n'est
capable de le supporter en plus ça va le
contracter sur une partie qui est
alimenté par deux les mici part de
l'énergie décarbonée donc ça n'évite pas
l'effort qu'il faut faire de toute façon
à côté sur la partie carbonée donc en
gros on se prend un double effort sans
avoir hiérarchiser les risques
c'est-à-dire sans s'être posé la
question de savoir s'il y en a un qui
était plusieurs gens que l'autre parce
que le risque la sanction à ne pas le
faire est plus lourde d'un côté que de
l'autre donc à un premier magistrat qui
serait une première liste rate qui
serait anti nucléaire prend l'option en
fait de rajouter à l'effort qui est
demandé aux français alors même que les
français n'ont pas bien compris le
niveau de l'effort qu'on allait leur
demander et pour en revenir au débat
qu'on a eue sur le pib en fait ça
revient à dire qu'on va leur demander un
effort de sobriété considérablement plus
importants et une sobriété que vous
n'avez pas désiré ça s'appelle de la
pauvreté c'est quelque chose que j'ai
souvent évoqué auprès de mes étudiants
pour leur donner les trois termes de ces
économies d'énergie l'efficacité c'est
quand vous avez le même service en
consommant moins d'énergie la sobriété
c'est quand vous souhaitez vous passez
vous du service et du coup vous avez
besoin d'énergie et la pauvreté c'est
quand on vous impose de vous passer du
service mais du coup vous concevez aussi
moins d'énergie la grosse différence
entre la sobriété et la pauvreté c'est
que la sobriété et choisit donc vous
êtes maître de votre destin vous avez le
ressenti de quelqu'un qui pilotent sa
destinée et donc vous n'avez pas de
rancoeur
vous n'avez pas d'amertume et vous
n'avez pas envie de ruer dans les
brancards quand vous êtes quand on sait
la pauvreté on vous a imposé quelque
chose on vous a contraint quelque chose
vous avez un sentiment d'injustice et à
ce moment vous ruer dans les brancards
donc c'est les deux sont très très
différents est en fait un président anti
nucléaires aujourd'hui où le président
entend ni nucléaire en fait ce qu'il
fait en pratique c'est que il prend le
risque d'imposer à la population une
dose de pauvreté qu'il ira au delà de ce
que la population est capable de
supporter dans la joie et la bonne
humeur voilà en gros c'est ça que ça
veut dire si je suis extrêmement clair
donc je ne pense pas qu'il faille créer
la désillusion en promettant une
croissance qui ne sera pas là et je ne
pense pas qu'il faille en rajouter à
l'effort en supprimant un matelas et un
amortisseur qui mon propos restent eux
mêmes même si on est obligé de retirer
du service des réacteurs parce qu'ils
ont des problèmes de corrosion sur un
sirh pittsburgh ça ne change rien bath
comment on retire ces dix là mais on
garde quand même les autres donc le le
sujet et on essaye quand même de
construire les nouveaux réacteurs pour
remplacer ceux qu on a donc là là le
propos que je tiens est indépendant du
niveau qu'on arrivera à voir c'est juste
que moins on en a et plus la population
va devoir soit désirée de la sobriété
car j'insiste sur le fait qu'elle doit
être désirable c'est pas de la sobriété
c'est la pauvreté soit subir de la
pauvreté et s'il ya trop de pauvreté y
aura la révolte ça l'histoire est
malheureusement extrêmement riche
sur ce plan là voilà donc alors
maintenant si je réponds pas dépendre la
question est ce que je préfère
décroissante east et anti-nucléaires
croissanciste et pro nucléaire eh ben
c'est une affaire de paris c'est à dire
que c'est à quelle vitesse est-ce que
celui qui a la caractéristique qui
m'intéressent va aussi avoir un contre
décroissante east et paraître promettre
la décroissance ça n'a aucun intérêt
c'est un codicille de quelque chose qui
est concret ça je veux bien mais la
promettre en tant que tel j'y crois pas
du reste hôtel fidh bateau un mois
j'aurais bien aimé que ce soit la
candidate des verts pour la richesse du
débat mais pas une seconde est ce ça
fait élire comme président mais voilà
c'était pour la richesse du débat
j'aurais trouvé ça intéressant mais cela
étant c'est absolument pas un projet de
société de dire on va décroître points
ça ne peut être qu au mieux que c'est
une conséquence de ce que je vous
propose il faut l'accepter ça peut pas
être
si j'essaye de répondre avec moi la
question c'est le pari que je pourrais
faire sur à quelle vitesse est ce que
quelqu'un qui possède la caractéristique
qui m'intéressent va changer d'avis sur
la caractéristique qui m'intéresse pas
d'accord est ce que mon pari c'est est
ce que quelqu'un qui est décroissante
east et anti-nucléaires pas devenir
décroissante east et pro nucléaire est
en fait pas des croissants tismée ptf
east pluto
et à quelle vitesse quelqu'un qui est
croissante east et anti et pro nucléaire
va devenir pas croissanciste et pro
nucléaire je ne sais pas répondre à
cette question c'est pour ça que j'ai
pas répondu à la question en question
parce que je ne sais pas prendre un pari
sur la vitesse à laquelle changera très
honnêtement je ne sais pas je ne sais
pas j'ai pas j'ai pas d'avis sur la
question donc c'est pour ça que j'ai
beaucoup de mal à y arriver
alors
alors santé et fin de vie alors
ccg prendre le sujet santé je vais pas
prendre le sujet lundi enfin si je vais
prendre un peu mais pas pourquoi aucun
candidat ne parle de fin de vie avoir la
possibilité si on le désire de partir
dignement sans souffrance et au passage
économiser pas mal de co2 alors quand on
a fait le
[Musique]
party santé du pts la première chose
qu'on a regardé c'est qu'elle est l
empreinte carbone du système de soins et
donc on a un calcul à vous proposer qui
a été fait par l'équipe qui s'est occupé
de la de la santé dans le tpf et ce
calcul est de dire que le système de
soins représente à peu près 8 % de
l'empreinte carbone de la france alors
j'insiste sur le fait que c'est à peu
près maintenant à peu près ça veut pas
dire cinq ans et ça veut pas dire un
d'accord ça veut dire que l'ordre de
grandeur est le bon donc retenu en ordre
de grandeur c'est un petit 10 %
mon
on antériorité sur les sujets de carbone
me permettent de dire que c'est
exceptionnel que un raffinage d'un
calcul de cette nature conduit à changer
dans de grandes heures j'ai rarement vu
charges ponctuelles que j'ai jamais vu
ça
dans ma petite carrière de comptable du
carbone alors oui pour cent c'est très
loin d'être négligeable ça veut dire que
par exemple ces deux fois celle du
numérique
le en ordre de grandeur toujours 2 3 la
moitié de cette empreinte carbone vient
de la fabrication de tous les ce qu'on
appelle les dispositifs médicaux qui
sont utilisées dans le système de soins
et en particulier à l'hôpital donc là
dans vous allez trouver les cathéters
les seringue les les contrats s etc et
vous allez vous pouvez également les
médicaments et en gros cerfs quoi 50-50
à l'intérieur du puits les proportions
exactes en tête mais enfin c'est parti
de là et donc c'est la fabrication des
médicaments donc la fabrication des
principes actifs et des empannages des
médicaments etc
si on veut avoir un système de santé
plus sobre on comprend bien qu'il va
falloir utiliser moins
modulo l'efficacité énergétique que les
fabricants sont capables de faire sur ce
qu'ils fournissent on va devoir utiliser
quand même à un moment moins de choses
dans le domaine des médicaments il ya
probablement plus à gagner avec des
formulations intelligente l'absence du
gaspillage par exemple la délivrance à
l'unité j'avais pour tous ceux d'entre
vous qui ont eu à prendre des
médicaments dans leur vie typiquement
les antibiotiques pour les gamins on
vous dit tant que j'ai lu le temps du
jour et
vous donne des boîtes qui permettent
d'avoir tant que j'ai eu le temps de
jours et puis si ça se trouve on vous
donne de guatelli la deuxième boîte il
en restait trois quarts quand vous avez
fini traitement après vous vous
retrouvez avec des boîtes
d'antibiotiques et moitié vide et un peu
partout quoi bas typiquement la
délivrance à l'unité permet d'éviter ça
donc si on vous dit ces deux gélules par
jour pendant les jours ou des livres
c'est ce truc et vibre à 17h15 donc ça
ça permet évidemment de vendre moins de
médicaments alors pour revenir à la
question tout à l'heure sur est-ce que
c'est récessif par louis pour les labos
pharmacie récessif s'ils vendent moins
de médicaments ils vendent moins de
médicaments
par contre ça va pas heurter la qualité
des soins vous avez besoin d'anti des
eaux parce que vous avez un truc qui
sinon ils risquent dégénéré hier
septicémie bah vous aurez toujours aux
anti bio parce que sinon ça risque de
dégénérer en s'est hissé sur les
dispositifs médicaux ça va être un peu
plus compliqué mais en gros d'un
philosophie l'amène à partir du moment
où vous avez besoin de plastique pour
faire les poches pour faire des
perfusions par ma foi tant que vous avez
besoin de six poches qu'il avait besoin
du plastique en question et puis vous
avez des spécifications parce que vous
êtes dans le domaine sanitaire dont vous
pourriez pas faire absolument ce que
vous voulez vous avez des normes à
respecter donc il ya une partie à
l'évidence si je m'inspire de ce qui a
été fait en chapitres industrie du ppe f
où on dit grâce à l'amélioration
continue et on peut gagner 40% à
l'horizon de visibilité donc sur les
cinquante ans
sur les 100 % qu'on doit gagner il y en
a 40 qui peut venir de l'amélioration
continue c'est probablement pareil en ce
qui concerne les fournisseurs de
médicaments et dispositifs médicaux
quelques dizaines de pourcents ils
peuvent gratter en étant juste en
s'occupant du problème alors que pour le
moment il s'en fiche et dans le volet
santé l'ars est l'une des choses qu'on
fait pour qu'ils s'occupent du problème
c'est de les obliger à obliger les
fournisseurs a publié des empreintes
carbone avant achat ou avant
autorisation de mise sur le marché donc
avant que les médicaments soient
autorisées l'admission de marché ou
avant autorisation devant les hôpitaux
achète on leur dit on peut voir en
carbone bastringue sinon bah on n'achète
rien donc ces voix là mais il ya une
partie qui va devoir être fait sur entre
guillemets la sobriété des soins alors
comment est-ce qu'on organise la
sobriété des soins en diminuant par la
qualité des soins c'est ça la question
et bien la réponse qu'on va trouver et
qui n'est pas du tout une réponse de
jésuites qui est une réponse extrêmement
précis et extrêmement sérieuse c'est il
faut diminuer la quantité de soins dont
nous avons besoin et diminuer la
quantité de soins dont nous avons besoin
ça passe par quelque chose qui s'appelle
améliorer l'hygiène de vie améliorer la
prévention c'est évident qu'on a besoin
de moins de moyens lourds à l'hôpital
pour soigner des gens qui ont des
pathologies liées au tabac s'il ya moins
de gens qui fument donc la bonne
question c'est comment est ce qu'on fait
pour oak au sein de la population où il
y ait moins de gens qui aient envie de
fumer et je redis qui en veut pas mettre
les gens en prison parce qu'il fut lui
c'est pas ça l'idée aujourd'hui
et si on a ce genre de choses à ce
moment on aura besoin de moins de moyens
pour soigner les pathologies qui sont
liés alors j'ai pris l'exemple du tabac
à dessein puisque c'est la première
cause de morts évitables dans ce pays on
a exactement les mêmes problèmes avec
les sédentariser en ce moment je suis
parfaitement sédentaires par ma bouche
puisque je vais lui poser sur un
fauteuil et donc on a un sujet sur la
sédentarité on a un sujet sur la nature
de l'alimentation donc avec moi j'avais
proposé dans le groupe santé je sais
plus si l'on vit de manière aussi
explicite le salon pas interdire la
publicité à la télévision pour les
produits alimentaires gras et sucrés et
en fait quand vous regardez bien c'est à
peu près tout ce qui est marrant c'est
très rare qu'on vous fasse la pub à la
télévision pour les carottes râpées ou
pour du poisson que la peur c'est très
courant pour ceux qui sont pas
végétariens organe est donc ce qu'on va
vous faire en général c'est pour des
marques de confiserie que je ne nommerai
pas d'être des pâtes à partie dès que je
et c'est
ce que les américains appellent de la
junk food je trouve que c'est assez bien
illustré donc on a voit la publicité on
avait proposé favori tout cas j'aurais
trouvé rigolo qu'on met ça dans le volet
santé
mais c'est bien ça la philosophie
alors une fois que j'ai dit ça c'est
quoi la conséquence logique de ce que je
suis en train de dire sur la partie fin
de vie la partie fin de vie alors vous
connaissez cette blague probablement
c'est dans la dernière année de sa vie
qu'on coûte le plus cher à la sécu donc
c'est plus que trop quel humoriste avait
dit ben c'est bon mais on n'a qu'à
supprimer la dernière manière à mourir
non plus tôt alors c'est évidemment une
blague c'est un ventilo blague c'est à
dire que il ya probablement un défi qui
se pose à nous
à moi avant une bonne partie des gens
qui regardent pas ce que l'environnement
est un sujet john
qui est
comment est-ce qu'on traite
effectivement la fin de vie dans leur
stade bâton merdeux la dernière fois que
j'en ai parlé dans un canard et une
volée de bois vert de la part d'un
certain nombre de gens mais bon comme je
suis un peu maso je vais recommencer je
pense qu'on a un vrai débat à avoir dans
notre pays sur comment est-ce qu'on
traite ce sujet et est-ce qu'il est
légitime de consacrer des moyens
médicaux lourds à maintenir en vie des
gens qui pour partie ne le souhaite pas
j'insiste qui pour partie ne le souhaite
pas ou des gens qui sont dans des
conditions sanitaires tels que
manifestement ça n'a plus de sens aux
yeux de même s'il pouvait s'exprimer ou
aux yeux de la famille est donc la bonne
question c'est est ce qu'on devrait pas
s'orienter vers plus de soins palliatifs
donc dit autrement moi quand je mourrai
si je suis dans un état absolument
lamentable à 95 ans ou même avant je me
fiche bien que l'on me maintiennent dans
cet état pendant un an je m'en fous
complètement
j'ai pas envie du reste j'ai pas envie
d'imposer cette charge à la société j'ai
pas envie d'imposer cette charge à mes
proches
par contre j'ai pas envie de souffrir et
j'ai pas envie que
comment dire on me fasse mourir dans de
mauvaises conditions et je pense qu'il
ya un vrai débat avoir pense pas être un
cas isolé d'un certain nombre de gens
qui ne souhaite pas imposer à la société
cette charge d'avoir une prise en charge
médicale extrêmement lourde à un moment
où les avantages ne sont peut-être pas à
la hauteur
les farc ont fait donc une partie de la
sobriété c'est clair qu'elle est
associée c'est pour ça que je voulais
passer fort seconde détour par le plan
santé la fin là je suis en train de vous
livrer un commentaire personnel c'est
pas du tout traités dans la question du
volet santé mais dans la question de la
sobriété dans le système de soins c'est
évident qu'on aura à se poser la
question de la fin de vie pour les
personnes âgées je parle évidemment pas
des soins apportés aux gens qu'ils sont
jeunes c'est pas du tout simplement
sujet c'est la question de ce qu'on fait
avec des gens qui sont en fin de vie et
aujourd'hui il faudrait qu'on puisse
aborder de semble-t-il ce débat
qui aujourd'hui un débat qui est encore
une fois très affectif
traître et on va avoir essentiellement
dans le monde qui nous attend beaucoup
de débats difficiles afin beaucoup de
débats compliqués pour la croit plus à
l'arrière les débats simple et facile
malheureusement plus le temps va passer
et moyens draps donc celui là en fait
partie
non il s'agit pas de faire cela hiver
puisque je peux passer une réponse je
n'ai aucune envie de manger les grands
parents je pense pas que ça doit avoir
trait de moudre est
alors toujours dans le dans la même
catégorie il y avait une question
j'aimerais bien voir un tome
avec un p de manger précise avec bacon
belge
donc est ce que j'ai un jumeau belge qui
peut de pondre ça
chaque personne qui m'a posé la question
et qui rajoute plus sérieusement pour
les petits pays l'échelle nationale
n'est pas la bonne échelle il faudrait
un plan européen et donc du coup en fait
il veut un plan botché doit pas du tout
un plan belge c'est un coquin
alors plusieurs plusieurs éléments de
réponses liées à lié à ça le premier
c'est la méthode du pdf c'est à dire
aborder les problèmes d'abord souvent
que le physique
aborder les problèmes sous l'angle des
compétences dont on a besoin et des
ressources contingentes avec lesquels il
faut qu'on opère cette méthode elle est
parfaitement réplicable à n'importe quel
autre pays qui est du reste
on serait ravis d'apporter notre soutien
à nous le chiffre d'1 à des initiatives
similaires qui verrait le jour puisque
on pourrait leur apporter maintenant un
retour d'expérience rex comme on dit
chez les consultants sur le sur la façon
dont ça s'est déroulé en france on a du
reste alors pour le moment le livre pas
les secrets de fabrique mais on a des
discussions
avec des pays francophones sur justement
la possibilité de répliquer cette
démarche pour le cas du pays avec lequel
on avec le cafard ou plus exactement qui
concerne les qui concerne les
discussions
même pour la belgique est un petit pays
ça aurait tout à fait du sens de faire
un pub avec un p je précise pourquoi est
ce que ça aurait tout à fait du sens
parce que ce que nous avons voulu faire
avec le plan de transformation de
l'économie française c'est justement
quelque chose de français c'est à dire
quelque chose qui ne demande pas que
d'abord l'europe prenne une décision
dont nous serions dépendants c'est
justement ça donc c'est pas un plan anti
européen c'est un plan a et européens
c'est à dire un plan n'a pas besoin
d'une décision européenne pour se mettre
en avant on a décidé ça parce que nous
avons c'est un plan que l'on propose aux
prochains locataires ou la prochaine
locataire de l'élysée et le la prochaine
le locataire de l'elysée a à sa
disposition les outils législatifs et
réglementaires français il n'a pas à sa
réglementaires européens donc nous nous
sommes beaucoup creuser la cervelle pour
savoir qu'est ce qu'on pouvait lui
proposer d'actionner comme levier qui ne
demandent pas l'aval de l'europe
c'est ça le cahier des charges de départ
donc notre cahier des charges de départ
c'est on parle physique on parle
compétences et on parle levier qui sont
à la main de l'exécutif français et donc
la méthode que l'on serait ravi de voir
les belges ont répliqué c'est exactement
la même sait on parle physique on parle
compétences et on parle de ce qui est à
la main de l'exécutif belge alors il ya
une petite différence entre l'exécutif
belge et l'exécutif france elle sait que
la france est une monarchie élective
comme je le dis parfois au sens où le
locataire de l'elysée la locataire de
l'elysée à quantité de pouvoir
absolument hallucinant dans notre pays
comparer alors qu'ils passaient bien le
mal dit juste c'est un fait comparé à ce
que le gouvernement a comme pouvoir dans
beaucoup d'autres démocraties
occidentales
je le rappelle encore des choses que
j'ai des avis mais en france c'est le
gouvernement qui fait l'agenda du
parlement c'est le gouvernement qui
écrit les projets de loi donc quand le
parlement et de la couleur du président
de la république de la présidente de la
république est bien le parlement je vais
être un peu méchant pour les députés qui
regarderont peut-être cette vidéo mais
il n'est pas très loin d'être une
chambre d'enregistrement c'est tellement
vrai que si vous avez une initiative
parlementaire dubois de déposer par les
parlementaires
j'ai déposé qui est intelligente mais
qui ne vient pas de la couleur du parti
pouvoir en général c'est niet quelle que
soit la proposition qui est déposée donc
c'est bien la preuve que le parlement
est une chambre d'enregistrement il n'a
pas son autonomie de décision sinon même
la majorité présidentielle de temps
entre en déciderait de voter un truc qui
a été déposée par l'opposition parce que
c'est par con et que l'opposition ne
raconte pas nécessairement que des
conneries juste parce que c'est
l'opposition ou voorhees c'est notre cas
de figure est vide en cas de figure
éminente donc le brûle donc la
différence entre la france et la
belgique c'est que le gouvernement
français très très fort et du coup ceci
explique cela on est particulièrement
fondé à lui faire des reproches quand on
considère que le pays évolue pas dans la
bonne direction précisément parce que le
gouvernement énormément au pouvoir donc
c'est pas une absence de pouvoir et le
fait qu'il soit contraint par d'autres
contre-pouvoir qui la fait avancer c'est
évidemment très différent en belgique
puisque c'est un état fédéral et on l'a
vu il n'ya pas longtemps sur la passe
d'armes qui a eu entre le gouvernement
fédéral et le gouvernement flamand sur
cette question de la construction des
centrales à gaz qui doivent prendre le
relais des centrales nucléaires parce
que s'il ya plus de centrales nucléaires
et pas de centrales à gaz en relais et
que dans le même temps les allemands ont
supprimé leurs nucléaire et et français
envoient un peu moins et bien on peut
commencer à prendre les paris sur
l'approvisionnement belge d'électricité
voilà c'est à mon avis une question qui
est intéressante
voilà donc il n'y a pas de problème de
méthode pour que la belgique réplique
est au contraire il ya un vrai intérêt
mais encore une fois avec cette
subtilité qui est que les instances de
décision en belgique se présente pas
comme les instances de décision en
france
après est ce qu'on peut faire un peu
tout c'est à dire un plan de
transformation de l'économie européenne
alors la réponse est oui mais l'europe
c'est une construction politique et
c'est une construction politique qui
contrairement à ce que pensée n'est pas
un système purement descendant de la
commission et du parlement vers les
états membres parce que c'est les états
membres qui constituent la commission et
le parlement donc en fait c'est un jeu
d'arbitrage des pouvoirs dans lequel un
état membre fort demandant de façon
forte et j'ai envie de dire non
négociable que quelque chose soit fait
au niveau européen en général il
l'obtient dit autrement s'y est dit là
il ya une ligne rouge
le parlement peut voter ce que ou ce que
ce qu'il veut moi je n'irai pas aux
blancs c'est juste un niet c'est un veto
absolu en général ça qu'on vit l'europe
a donc pas prendre la décision qui irait
à l'encontre de la volonté d'un des deux
grands états membres pourraient être
beaucoup plus précis que son d'un des
deux états membres fondateurs que sont
l'allemagne et la france donc pour être
un peu plus précis aujourd'hui quand les
français 10 voix c'est l'europe qui a
décidé nous on n'y peut rien c'est
évidemment un raisonnement de l'autre on
vient de le voir du reste sur l'histoire
de la taxonomie européenne
là il y avait les yeux rouges la france
a dit c'est niet et l'allemagne reste
avec votre ligne rouge de gaz et donc on
va retrouver le gaz et le nucléaire
alors le nucléaire s'était justifié le
gaz n'allait pas mais peu importe enfin
ou de salé pas ça peut l'être aussi mais
ce n'est pas le débat du jour mais met
donc il ya la construction européenne
est une construction remontantes ce qui
veut dire que si on fait un boeuf nov et
que le pto fait une réussite c'est le
meilleur moyen que l'on fasse un peu
tout et durera jusqu'au 6 octobre et
peut-être un pathos pour l'économie
espagnole est peut-être plus tôt et
la gouvernance de la décarbonation elle
est exportable exactement comme la
france a historiquement exporter la
délégation de service public le système
métrique ou la tva donc ya pas de raison
ou le bilan carbone du reste la
comptabilité carbone aujourd'hui la
borne mondiale sur la comptabilité
carbone c'est le bilan carbone donc ça
n'appelle pas pareil mais c'est ça donc
la france que très bien exportée la
gouvernance de la décarbonation à partir
du moment où ça marche bien j'ai donc la
meilleure option on puisse prendre c'est
ça le sens de ma longue réponse pour
qu'on ait un peu c'est que le prof soit
une réussite chez nous c'est à dire que
l'on fasse la preuve dans les faits que
ce travail ça ce sont sa diffusion et
les faits qui les faits observables
qu'il aura dans le pays soit probant
voilà donc c'est donc c'est donc si
notre truc ça reste une élucubration
intellos qui se sont bien amusés dans
leur coin en volant les pizzas
il n'y aura pas de but ou si ce qu'on
fait intéresse une fraction suffisamment
intérêts importante de la population
pour que à un moment ça se traduise en
décisions politiques alors y en a un
piteux voilà c'est en groupe comme ça
que je veux peut-être que la personne
qui m'a posé la question et bien
gentilles car jean cau et enfin s'il ya
un peu de 15 ans après parce que c'est
ça le temps qu'il faut pour faire la
preuve en france ben on est totalement
hors course oui effectivement je prends
le point que je me suis donné un mois
mais loue le mauvais point que celui-ci
l'aider à moi même c'est absolument
évident que dans une course contre la
montre on n'a pas la nuit pour faire la
preuve que ça fonctionne donc
effectivement on est intéressés nous
faire la preuve que ça fonctionne
rapidement mais quand même il faudra le
temps qu'il se passe quelque chose en
france pour que la démarche soit
reproduit temps réel
alors alors après
continuant faut-il sortir des traités
européens pour appliquer ce plan je vais
répondre à la question non il faut pas
sortir des traités européens justement
c'est un plan qui s'applique à traiter
constants
après je vais prendre une question dans
un domaine tout à fait différent
puisque ça aussi beaucoup de laïcs qui
est la suivante le rapport de rtl futur
énergétique 2050 at il été pris en
compte dans l'élaboration du prof et si
oui cela at il modifié certaines
perspectives notamment du point de vue
de la place accordée au nucléaire et le
nerfs dans le mix énergétique
jancovici étant souvent critiqué pour le
ton et les arguments qu'il emploie pour
valoriser la filière nucléaire et
dévaloriser les yeux et d'air
alors réponse en plusieurs points
la réponse courte si oui en fait la
version le volet énergétique du plan de
transformation de l'économie française
c'est le scénario n 03 de rte se faire
celui qui comporte le plus de nucléaire
donc on sait parfaitement appuyé sur les
travaux de rte pour faire nos propres
propositions du reste nous avons eu
depuis maintenant quelques années des
discussions
très intéressantes avec arte e alors
dans le passé il est arrivé d'être un
peu taquin pour rester polie sur la
façon dont on abordait la prospective
électrique en france mais depuis
quelques années on a noué un dialogue
intéressant et en particulier le chi
project avait fait il ya maintenant
j'espère que si nicolas bay coûte il ne
ment verra pas ça va être pourri à la
figure en france on sait pas la saison
des tomates je sais plus si c'est trois
ans quatre ans cinq ans devant mais
enfin quelques années on a fait un gros
travail qui s'appelait power systems
2050 et qui était un discours de la
méthode sur la façon de réaliser un
scénario énergétique complet à ces
dérives électrique complète un lapsus
coupable responsable c'est quoi un
scénario électrique complet c'est un
scénario qui est capable de décrire la
totalité des contreparties qui sont
associées au fait de suivre une
trajectoire
ces contreparties peuvent être
économiques peuvent être le demande en
matériaux une demande en espace que
mettre en concurrence d'usagé des sols
peuvent être et c'est toutes les
contreparties tous les éléments qu'un
décideur doit avoir pour prendre une
décision et arbitrer entre les diverses
possibilités
qui la kia soul je crois pouvoir dire en
toute immodestie cependant fait le
boulot que ce travail a permis de
nourrir le travail que rta engagé sur la
scénarisation électrique puisque moi
j'ai pas encore lu malheureusement j'ai
pas j'arrive pas à trouver le temps de
faire ça les quasiment 600 pages du
rapport mais j'ai lu raisonnablement
attentivement les 80 ou 85 pages du
voile et environnemental il ce volet
environnemental comporte beaucoup
d'indications qui pour moi sont des
indications en fait c'est les
indications les plus pertinentes voilà
la partie économique et je veux dire
après pourquoi pense que ce n'est pas là
l'essentiel
la partie vraiment intéressante parce
qu'elle est c'est la philosophie du
potager pour vous dire inverse c'est
celle qui concerne la partie ressources
physiques donc c'est en fonction de la
trajectoire qu'on suit de combien de
métal on a besoin de compte il ya des
espaces on a besoin de combien c'est ça
c'est ça le
parti que j'ai regardé de plus près
et
du coup en retour on sait bien
évidemment inspiré du travail de rte
pour le scénario alors on a été un peu
plus prudent q verte et c'est là que je
vais en tenir sur deux points
d'abord le premier c'est sûr nous on
reprend pas à notre compte le volet
économique parce que j'avais dit tout à
l'heure l'économie et d'une convention
est du reste rte est parfaitement
conscient de cette affaire-là puisque
nous avons eu des discussions avec eux
sur la manière dont on pourrait
éventuellement faire une variante sur le
plan économique
liée à une hypothèse qui est après être
descendu le prix des nerfs remonte et
dire pourquoi ils seraient priés de
venir montrer le prix élevé des re
pourraient remonter pour une raison très
simple c'est que les dispositifs de
collecte des énergies renouvelables donc
les panneaux solaire les éoliennes les
câbles les dispositifs de stockage
demande des matériaux sa demande en
particulier du métal et c'est en demande
plus que le système électrique
conventionnelle que nous avons
aujourd'hui on et du charbon du gaz du
nucléaire
à partir du moment où ça demande plus de
métal si vous commencez à avoir une
contrainte importante sur les énergies
fossiles que ce soit pour repérer les
mines pour opérer les usines
métallurgiques pour opérer la
transformation manufacturière pour
opérer les industries chimiques dont
vous avez besoin pour faire des
composants de ces collecteurs et à
partir du moment où vous avez une
contrainte sur le pétrole ce qui va
nécessairement quoi qu'on en dise
limiter le commerce international donc
la mondialisation or aujourd'hui tous
les panneaux qu'on installe en france
ils sont faits en chine et une bonne
partie des éoliennes en installant
france sont en fait en france donc si
demain matin vous avez plus de bateaux
aux plus de camions plus d'avions sauf
la petite partie qui sera électrique il
est évident que ça sera un peu plus
compliqué de transporter partout dans le
monde des gros tonnage de matériaux ou
des gros tonnage de métaux ça la
contrepartie économique de cette affaire
ça s'appelle une hausse du prix
vlc ça en pratique ça venir donc vous
avez une option qui à titre personnel ne
paraît tout à fait normal à explorer
j'aime bien normal explorer dans une
optique ou me chercher à voir quels sont
les risques contre lesquels vous
chercher à les couvrir et bien un gay
risque c'est que après avoir baissé le
prix des dispositifs de collecte et des
câbles et des machins se mettent à
augmenter et à ce moment plus vous avez
besoin de métal de câbles de dispositifs
de collecte et de dispositifs de
stockage qui sont aussi largement du
métal enfin pour les batteries et plus
le coût global de votre système va
augmenter donc la question de savoir
donc la trajectoire économique qui est
celle sur laquelle se basent rte qui est
le prix des oeufs nerfs continue à
baisser moi je mets ce km/heure en
disant il faut mettre en gras et en
rouge que ça ça suppose que la
productivité que aujourd'hui les
énergies fossiles nous ont apporté sur
le système industriel mondial se
conserve à l'avenir voilà dans un monde
dans lequel nous n'avons plus les
énergies fossiles et ma part c'est un
énorme caviar la deuxième chose donc rte
dit pas le contraire puisqu'ils sont
transparents sur les hypothèses qui
utilisent par contre dans
l'interprétation de ce volet là du
scénario de rte faut être prudent
puisque encore une fois il faut
souscrire à l'hypothèse de départ et rte
ne dit pas ils disent c'est celle qu'on
a prises 10 passes et celles qui en
notre âme et conscience nous paraît la
plus probable du succès c'est
la deuxième chose sur laquelle nous on
n'a pas d'argent donc ptf donc là je
fais une digression personnel la
deuxième chose sur laquelle on a été
prudent c'est qu'on dit et ça a été très
très clairement dit par nicolas riard
quand on a présenté le pts à sciences po
lundi dernier il a dit en fait toutes
options qu'on peut prendre comporte des
risques tout y compris l'option
nucléaire
alors le risque majeur de l'option
nucléaire il n'est pas contrairement à
ce que peuvent penser un certain nombre
de gens peut-être le risque qu on ait un
accident
si on regarde les faits parce que le
plus probable si on a un accident en
france c'est que ça soit un accident du
type three mile island c'est à dire on
perd le réacteur
plus
le canton perd en usine chimique comme
azf ont dit pas on va sortir de chez lui
parce qu'on a perdu une du chili et en
plus ça fait des morts
des mises et les morts et plus de faire
en sorte que cet acquis des relations
tendues ce pas mais on y va on va sortir
le chili est le plus d'avoir de savon du
shampooing
donc sur nucléaire si on gère exactement
de la même manière bon il ya un risque
d'accident mais c'est un risque qui ne
se gère comme un accident industriel
voilà les bus mois
le point important dans le nucléaire
c'est le risque de ne pas arriver au
bout du programme parce qu'on a un
défaut de compétence ou un défaut de
réglementation intelligente alors à
défaut de réglementation intelligente
c'est qu'on se met des contraintes qui
sont au-delà de celles que l'on peut
auquel on peut satisfaire et à ce moment
nous fait pas parce que les contraintes
sont trop durs et pas nécessairement de
manière justifiée et il ya un défaut de
compétence le d une centrale nucléaire
ça c'est un truc qui est quand même plus
compliqué à construire et à installer
qu'un panneau solaire c'est absolument
évident
ce qui est compliqué dans le solaire
c'est pas de faire le panneau c'est de
faire le système et c'est une complexité
d'organisation c'est pas une complexité
technique il ya des limites physiques
mais la complicité elle et
d'organisation
le en ce qui concerne le nucléaire la
complexité dans la construction d'une
centrale parce que la centrale c'est un
peu plus compliqué et donc c'est
compliqué donc l'après limite du
nucléaire c'est une élite en compétences
et ludivine en réglementation et donc il
ya un vrai risque si on prend l'option
nucléaire quand sera pas prêt à temps
parce qu'à part les compétences et qui a
pas la bonne réglementation est un des
trucs qui tue les compétences et qui
fait une réglementation excessivement
prudente c'est le stop and go qu'on n'a
eu depuis 20 ans dans ce pays un coup
j'en fais j'en fais plus en faire plus
ça c'est très très mauvais pour les
compétences c'est un peu comme si pour
tous les gens qui regardent qui sont en
train de suivre des études imaginons que
vous soyez de l'entrain de suivre des
études parce que vous avez envie de
devenir mécanicien automobile et puis un
coup on vous dira plus d'autos parce
qu'à des vo puis dans à bout d'ici six à
des autos quand même et puis le
surlendemain il n'ya plus d'autos parce
qu'il ya des vélos vous comprenez bien
que dans ce genre de contexte vous avez
une petite hésitation sur ce que vous
devez continuer vos études vous êtes
moyens motivée par rapport à si on vous
dit dans garantie quant à des voitures
comprenez bien c'est exactement ça pour
les compétences et puis même si on vous
dit ça tous les quatre matins si vous
réfléchissez si vous hésitez entre une
formation mécanicien pour voitures et
avocats et bien
je dirais plutôt avocat que mécanicien
qu'en voiture donc le
donc à partir du moment où vous avez du
stop and go vous avez nécessairement un
déficit sur les compétences c'est
absolument évident alors l'idée braquent
violent en ce moment mais mais mais de
fait scénariste et pareil pour
l'agglomération donc sur l'option
nucléaire on le dit très clairement il
ya un risque de ne pas aller au bout à
cause du fait qu' on ne sera pas
suffisamment déterminée et constant dans
le programme combien du côté
renouvelables il ya un risque de ne pas
aller au bout parce que nous allons buté
sur d'autres limites donc je parlais
tout à l'heure des limites en matériaux
l' agence internationale de l'énergie a
dit y'a pas longtemps sur les mines de
cuivre en exploitation on s'approche
probablement du pic de production mais
bien la doctrine qu'on pourrait mettre
tout est ok mais plus vous mettez des
nouvelles mines en opération et plus en
général la teneur en métal de la mine
est faible donc c'est des mines qui ont
un moins bon rendement sont plus
d'énergie pour extraire le métal plus
d'énergie pour extraire le métal pour
faire le système énergétique on n'est
qu'à un moment il ya un truc de bouclage
qui qui qui l'a pas une rétroaction
négative qui va s'amplifier
donc vous avez un risque sur la
disponibilité des métaux qui se traduira
en termes économiques par l'inflation
dont je parlais tout à l'heure et du
reste l'inflation sur les panneaux
solaires sauf erreur de ma part avait
déjà commencé alors je sais pas s'il ya
un effet posco vite c'est le début d'un
renversement tendance j'en sais rien
mais vous avez cet effet là vous avez un
effet sur la disponibilité en espace
j'ai calculé qu'aujourd'hui il y avait
déjà deux ennemis ou trois millions de
français qui étaient
à qui voyait une éolienne depuis leur
domicile
et en général quand on voit l'éolienne
depuis le domicile de quelqu'un la
valeur patrimoniale du domicile baisse
voilà c'est un truc que vous disent les
agents immobiliers s'est en fait encore
une fois on peut considérer que c'est un
coup que la collectivité doit assumer
mais c'est un fait
donc ce qui va se passer et puis vous
voyez aussi avec la manière dont ça se
passe dans le dans le débat le vrai
risque pour les renouvelables c'est
qu'heuliez un écart entre ce qu'on
imagine que les gens vont être prêts à
accepter en termes d'occupation par les
dispositifs de collecte et
ce qui va vraiment se passer c'est à
dire qu'à un moment il va y avoir du
freinage de ce côté là on n'a pas une
arrive pas à déployer à temps ci a pas
suffisamment d'endroits où il ya
personne et on peut mettre assez
d'éoliennes et de panneaux solaires où
il n'y a pas suffisamment de matériau
pour y arriver où il n'ya pas les
contreparties on doit à voir par
ailleurs qui sont le stockage parce que
rtl très clair sur le fait que même les
scénarios à 50% de nucléaire il ya
besoin de plus de stockage et
l'interconnexion aujourd'hui
les l'effacement le voilà donc là pour
vous prendre un exemple très récent si
vous allez sur le site de rte vous
regardez la production éolienne et
solaire du mois de janvier qui vient de
s'écouler vous verrez qu'il ya eu deux
épisodes de vent un peu significatif sur
l'ensemble du mois de janvier que le
reste du temps la production était
extrêmement faible et comme nous sommes
en hiver le soleil est bas sur l'horizon
la production solaire est également
également faible et en plus nulles
toutes les nuits donc voilà typiquement
un noir dans lequel si vous n'avez pas
des moyens de stockage et si vous n'avez
pas une manière de compenser vous êtes
un peu dans les moyens de compenser il
ya également les interconnexions mais
les interconnexions augmente votre
dépendance aux pays voisins donc là à ce
moment vous reporter le risque sur est
ce que les pays voisins vont vraiment
faire ce qui est nécessaire pour nous
fournir de l'électricité quand nous
allons en avoir besoin dit autrement est
ce que les pays voisins ils auront une
politique résolument exportatrices quand
nous nous avons besoin d'être
importateurs ou est ce qu'ils vont juste
s'occuper de leurs propres problèmes et
il n'aura pas d'électricité en plus pour
nous quand on en a besoin tout ça c'est
des points d'interrogation c'est des
risques alors pour aller au bout de
cette longue digression ça veut dire que
le pari que nous avons pris enfin le
pari que la position directement nous a
compris aussi le projet c'est de dire on
se cale sur rtl pour la partie qu'on
considère comme acquises la partie qu'on
considère comme acquises c'est le
nucléaire historique on continue à faire
fonctionner - les centrales qui
arriveront en fin de vie certaines à 40
d'autres à 50 d'autres à 72 peut-être à
70 il va y avoir un panachage sur
l'ensemble des réacteurs qu'on a si
notre seule limite est une limite
technique c'est à dire on les retire du
service quand l'asn dit elle sans plus
bonne pour le service à ce moment mais
de durée de vie vont pas et hélène ont
rajouté quelques réacteurs 9 donc pour
le moment on s'est calé sur ce que la
filière deee pouvoir construire sachant
que ma conviction personnelle c'est que
si on se met dans un contexte allez je
vais être un peu taquin chinois ou russe
c'est à dire avec un pouvoir central où
nous avons l'absolue certitude qu'il ne
va plus variés sur les 30 ans qui
viennent mon ma conviction c'est qu'on
ira plus vite que ce que l'industrie dit
pouvoir faire aujourd'hui
parce que historiquement c'est ce qui
s'est passé et parce que les américains
ont réorienté un tiers de leur pib en
trois ans quand il était en berne donc à
partir du moment où il ya un sentiment
d'urgence et une constance de côté du
pouvoir politique mon sentiment c'est
qu'on dit c'est qu'on peut avec le 8 mai
s'est pas prononcée avec mon sentiment
donc on s'est calé sur scénario de rte
sur la partie du caire on s'est calé sur
donc nous on n'est pas égoïste on veut
pas démonter les éoliennes existantes
les olives existantes on les garde
jusqu'à la fin de leur vie et pour le
reste on dit on n'a pas encore
suffisamment regardé le problème de
suffisamment prêt malgré le travail
remarquable de rte pour être capable
d'arbitrer de façon totalement assurée
entre les diverses options qui sont pour
le reste on fait que de nerfs que du
nucléaire ou un panachage voilà on
considère qu'aujourd'hui le suggère pas
encore été suffisamment creusé pour
qu'on soit capable d'arbitrer alors vous
allez me dire sauf que à court terme
qu'est ce qu'on fait quand même prendre
des décisions par à court terme et fait
feu de tout bois donc à court terme on
continue à construire des oeillères là
où ça emmerde pas trop les gens et là où
manifestement on a encore un petit gain
à faire sur le fossile qui est apporté
une faucille français ont fait
exactement ce que macron a dit qu'il
allait faire c'est à dire on développe
du nouveau nucléaire et pour le reste on
se dépêche de creuser beaucoup plus
sérieusement la question pour voir
comment est ce qu ont instruit beaucoup
mieux les risques que je viens d'évoquer
jusqu'à maintenant donc il faut qu'on
ait une vision plus claire et des
passionnés par
tétanisé des passionnés des risques je
vais répondre à la deuxième et c'est
urgent je vais répondre à la deuxième
partie de la question qui est ce que
j'ai changé d'avis sur l'arbitrage de
nerfs nucléaire non je n'ai pas changé
d'avis je continue à considérer que le
nucléaire est supérieur à l'éolien et au
solaire continue à considérer c'est une
énergie plus compact qui demandent moins
de matériaux qui fait qu'ils engendrent
plus de valeur ajoutée situés pour le
seul français qui est beaucoup plus
simple à gérer dans un réseau et qu'il
n'est pas plus dangereuse en tout cas
compte tenu des précautions que nous
prenons en france est ce que ça veut
dire que pour autant il faut s'interdire
de rajouter une éolienne dans ce pays
donc pas nécessairement est-ce que mais
là on est dans la realpolitik j'ai envie
on n'est pas dedans est-ce qu'il y en a
une qui a sur le papier vertus supérieur
à l'autre
pas exactement la même question mais je
n'ai pas changé d'avis sur la hiérarchie
des performances
on va changer d'avis là dessus par
contre j'ai je n'ai jamais dit je crois
que c'était une ânerie de faire des
nerfs points non seulement j'ai jamais
dit mais j'ai toujours dit la verse j'ai
toujours dit que c'était
circonstancielle cette affaire est donc
si les circonstances en france font que
c'est intelligent parce que à court
terme ça permet de gratter un petit
quelque chose à rajouter un peu ça me
pose pas après il faut pas faire ça
n'importe comment et donc même si c'est
un peu plus cher je préfère par exemple
pour rajouter des panneaux solaires sur
les toits des maisons plutôt que en
supprimant de la forêt
donc je continue à considérer que soit
le contexte ul et qu' il faut pas être
mon maniaque dans cette affaire mais je
le jeu insiste à titre personnel je n'ai
pas changé d'avis sur la hiérarchie
alors
ensuite
donc ça j'ai répondu
sur le sur la question sur le
développement du nucléaire
j'ai
beaucoup mais ça j'ai répondu également
ça j'ai répondu ça vire est contenue
dans la question l ai répondu également
allés sur la politique on va dire qu'on
a à peu près fait
j'ai une question un peu en charge de
l'avc pour une prochaine fois désolé
pour la personne qui a posé la question
sur la pompe à chaleur peut-être contrat
de cession bâtiment un jour ça sera plus
ça va
dans dans l'ensemble
a alors ça c'est une question papeete ef
nos risques de fonte de l'iceberg en
antarctique
et est-ce qu'on a enrichi l'angers sco
répond très rapidement est ce que le
risque qu on ait une montée des eaux de
3 mètres et d'une forte portée à 5 ans
non zéro risque à 5 ans à zéro risque de
montée des eaux à 30
énergie électricité a alors ça c'est
au vu de la crise actuelle de l'énergie
et de la position de l'état demandé à
edf de payer pour ses concurrents que
préconisez vous pour l'avenir de
l'électricité est resté dans un marché
commun en sortir nationalisée
alors
je vais très directement cette question
ça fait 20 ans que je considère que
d'avoir
ouvert la concurrence à laval sur
l'électricité est une ânerie
pour la fois que je les ai christ il ya
20 ans alors je n'avais pas identifié
très exactement ce qui allait se passer
donc j'ai pas ma tribu c'est mérité mais
j'avais identifié que ça allait
compliquer de structurer des acteurs à
partir du moment où il était en
concurrence les uns avec les autres
c'est quoi la différence entre
concurrence à laval et la confiance elle
la concurrence à l'annoncé d'hier bon on
a actuellement un parc de production
électrique en france j'ai pas envie
d'avoir qu'edf en face de moi donc je
coupe le truc en deux et je fais deux
sociétés et puis quand il y en a une qui
me sort par les trous mais je fais appel
à l'autre et quand je logeais pour gérer
que centrale données c'est également
exactement comme le duo paul veolia suez
qu'on a eu longtemps dans l'eau
quand y'en a un qui ne va pas je fais un
appel d'offres et je prends le retrait
de licence saas à peu à l'arrière
fonctionner parce que ça vous laisse des
sociétés qui ont une intensité enfin ça
vous laisse des sociétés qui sont
grosses avec des moyens d'investissement
qui ont la possibilité d'assumer des
investissements lourds et juste en gros
se ressemblent un peu elle travaille
ensemble mais
l'intérêt de la joie et accessoirement
probablement discutable mais on va faire
ça la concurrence à la balle c'est le
système que nous avons monté qu'il a pas
de réalité physique parce qu'il faut
bien voir que quand vous changez de
fournisseurs sur le papier rien ne
change chez vous vous dérange pas les
fils pour vous les rebrancher on vous il
ya personne qui vient dans la rue
tripoter les câbles etc et on n'a pas
brancher directement sur votre compteur
même si on vous dit qu'on vous vend
l'électricité verte les éoliennes et les
panneaux solaires de france où les
barrages transilien surtout des barrages
excessive non c'est le même réseau
qu'avant exactement le même qui vous
amène les mêmes électrons qu'avant
exactement les mêmes par le même câble
qu'avant exactement le même donc en fait
tout ça c'est purement conventionnelle
ça n'a aucune espèce de réalité physique
un bon vous changer de fournisseur en
fait vous ne changez de rien on a créé
là dedans un marché dans lequel les
fournisseurs s'approvisionnent en gros
auprès d'eux des producteurs donc en
fait c'est c'est des purs distributeurs
donc là dedans vous en avait
quelques-uns construite centrale par ci
par là petite mais globalement c'est des
purs distributeurs qui n'ont rien
construit du tout ils ont simplement
capter une partie de la marge qu'avant
et df captait pour ses besoins 30 vous
pouvez très bien dire edf les gens
étaient trop payés il y avait trop de
vacances ils ont un comité d'entreprise
qui possède trop de pognon très bien
mais c'est des problèmes qui j'ai en
tant que tel si on le pense et il n'est
pas normal que les agents edf
électricité à 10% du prix que très bien
on traite le problème en tant que tel
donc on vit les agents opérants
l'électricité 100 % du prix arriveront
cependant avec un joueur en plus très
bien sans vous
on va pas
dézinguer les df pour traiter un
problème qui se traitent en tant que tel
et c'est exactement pareil pour les
sujets de rémunération de retraite etc
des problèmes qui se traitent en tant
que tel ça n'a rien à voir on va pas
créer des concurrents edf juste parce
que l'on pense que les gens d elles sont
trop payés sur quoi j'ai pas d'avis tout
de suite du last
en ce qui concerne le donc on a créé des
entités et en plus ces entités ne sont
même pas des concurrents car ces entités
sont des dépendants la boule devant le
la branche de 10 n'est pas dépendante du
peuplier sur lequel ou du pommier
exactement sur lequel elle pousse
les parcs jantes elle en est dépendante
si vous coupez le pommier la bande le
gamer donc là c'est exactement pareil si
vous supprimez physiquement et df en
france les concurrents me donc en fait
c'est pas des concurrents cdd pendant
un concurrent c'est carbone4 vis-à-vis
d'autres sociétés qui font qu'ils
vendent des prestations dans le monde
financier ou dans le monde des
entreprises si demain matin on supprime
mackinsey 44 ne meurt pas le problème en
même que car le 4 x de meilleures
affaires donc c'est ça la concurrence la
vraie concurrence là c'est pas un marché
concurrentiel qu'on a organisées c'est
un truc c'est un c'est un truc de bric
et de broc aucune espèce de
signification et qui est née parce que
quelques gély je ne sais pas où
vu un jour concurrence partout en europe
et se dire tiens l'électricité n'y a pas
de concurrence c'est pas bien c'est
juste trop bien on va mettre de la
concurrence en électricité mais c'est un
truc qui est artiste totalement
artificielle ça n'a aucune espèce d'exit
ça n'a aucune espèce d'existence dans le
monde physique
une fois que j'ai dit tout ça
si j'étais aux manettes ce qu'est ce que
je ferai eh bien je fais linverse que ce
qui a été fait aujourd'hui car je
réintègre tout c'est très simple je
refais une entité publique je vois
absolument pas l'intérêt d'avoir 12 %
d'une entité publique cotée en bourse on
voit juste pas l'intérêt la cotation en
bourse n'a d'intérêt qu'à partir du
moment où vous avez l'intention de lever
de l'argent donc que monsieur elon musk
aille en bourse c'est parfait parce qu
avec la valorisation des cela monsieur
elon musk fait une augmentation de
capital de 20 ans sans qui le dit lui
absolument pas et il a 10 milliards pour
faire joujou parfaite donc ça c'est
quelque chose qui peut critiquer le
mécanisme même de la finance qui lui
permet d'avoir 10 milliards si
facilement mais en attendant il les
accords quel est l'intérêt pour edf
d'avoir 12% du capital strictement aucun
joueur pour un service intégré
d'électricien aucun intérêt donc la
question de la détention du capital pour
moi est réglée par le fait que ça n'a
strictement aucune espèce d'intérêt et
que par ailleurs dans les
investissements très lourds qui sont
faits dans l'électricité il ya un
élément qui est central dans le coût
auquel vous allez pouvoir produire qui
est le coût du capital alors je suis
désolé je vais rentrer dans les détails
techniques le coût du capital
c'est les intérêts que chaque année les
intérêts et les dividendes que chaque
année les actionnaires et les banquiers
vous demandent de leur verser pour vous
avoir mis à disposition l'argent qui
allez vous permettre de construire
quelque chose une centrale à gaz une
éolienne c'est un réacteur nucléaire
barrage peu importe
pour
le nucléaire vous avez compris que
c'était quelque chose que j'aimais bien
qui est une installation qui va mettre
dix ans à être construite alors cinq ans
si on est très performant comme les
chinois plus de dix ans si on remet les
mains dans bruit pour la première fois
avec on prend garde tard dans tous les
sens mais on revient c'est derrière un
engin qui va fonctionner 60 ans et si
vous regardez
l'impact sur un engin qui dure aussi
longtemps et pour lequel tous les coups
sont à payer au moment où vous
construisez parce que en gros un
réacteur nucléaire et des coûts de
maintenance de combustible qui sont très
faibles comparé au coût de construction
donc tout le coup arrive au début et
ensuite vous rentabilisez ou de
construction au fur et à mesure en
remboursant à vos banquiers et à vos
actionnaires l'argent qui vous ont prêté
une donnée investi pour avoir permis de
construire le réacteur est bien
évidemment cet argent vous le rembourser
avec intérêts et bien pour 1 2 p r qui
va coûter 10 milliards à construire
alors celui de flamanville coup plus
cher tant porte 10 milliards c'est
l'ordre de grandeur
selon que vous devez rembourser le coût
de construction avec des intérêts à 2%
temps vous n'avez pas fini de rembourser
ou avec des intérêts à 10 % et 10 %
c'est le rendement sur capital investi
que vous vont vous exigez des
actionnaires financiers et les 'points
et le cas eh bien vous allez avoir ou
pas 90 milliards je dis bien 90
milliards de frais financiers à
rembourser sur la vie du réacteur pour
un réacteur qui est bien construit 10
milliards à construire donc si vous
passer de 2 à 10 %
90 milliards de frais financiers en plus
à construire a avancé le coût du
mégawattheure à hinkley point c'est
avant tout un coup de frais financiers
les gens qui vous bénéficiez des 120 ou
130 ou 140 euros chez lui le
mégawattheure dit l'épaule c'est avant
tout des banques et des actionnaires
c'est pas avant tout le prix de
l'électricité que vous allez payer
coût de construction de la centrale
donc une fois que je vous ai dit ça vous
comprenez bien que 1 nucléaire pas cher
c'est pas nucléaire qui empruntent et
qui disposent de capitaux pour pas cher
et qu'elle est l'entité dans n'importe
quel pays qui emprunte pour pas cher
l'étape donc là je vous ai donné une
partie de la réponse si on veut avoir un
système et c'est pareil pour les yeux
des reins soit dit en passant les nerfs
vont payer tout à la construction et
après vous payer quasiment rien en
maintenance et en exploitation donc si
vous voulez avoir de l'électricité pas
trop cher et même si on n'a pas parlé
argent dans le pdf ça peut être un
objectif est dur est derrière vous
pouvez la taxe et une fois qu'elle est
produite pour passer par un sujet si
vous voulez que les gens pensent est 4e
mais si vous voulez qu'elle soit
produite pour pas trop cher et bien à ce
moment ce qui peut avoir beaucoup
d'intérêt pour réindustrialiser en
france des trucs aujourd'hui on apporte
notamment dans la production d'un
certain nombre de matériaux intensifs en
énergie l'aluminium est bel et bien à ce
moment vous avez besoin d'emprunter à
pas cher donc vous avez besoin que ce
soit empruntée par un organisme public
ayant la garantie d'état points donc là
je vous ai donné à la conso si ça veut
dire que si on veut reconstruire un parc
nucléaire bien foutu on a besoin d'avoir
la garantie de l'état pour emprunter
pour pas cher et on n'a surtout pas
besoin d'avoir des investisseurs privés
qui vont arriver en disant que les -10%
parce que c'est la norme du marché
après il ya un autre sujet qui est est
ce que j'ai besoin d'avoir plein de
sociétés en concurrence à laval la
réponse est non où va l'argent des
distributeurs il va pour partie dans les
salaires des gens qui vous vend de
l'électricité
donc vous avez bien compris qu'en fait
c'était la même qu'avant mais ces gens
là vous pourriez aussi bien les
réintégrer dans un service public parce
que à partir du moment où vous avez un
certain nombre de clients vous avez
besoin d'avoir un certain nombre de gens
en face et c'est le nombre d'appels que
vous pouvez traiter par heure qui
conditionne de gens dont on a besoin
qu'ils soient dans un service public ou
toile extérieure
peut très bien
et pour le reste l'argent va dans les
marches et donc les dividendes des
actionnaires privés
qui opère sa société est ce que l'argent
il est mieux investis au profit de la
collectivité quand il va comme
dividendes des actionnaires privés
l'aragon c'est pas sûr il vaudrait mieux
que cet argent reste dans le giron de la
société qui a besoin de développer et
d'investir et de maintenir et de
remplacer le parc de centrales
électriques dont vous avez besoin donc
tout ça quand vous dire que pour
employer un gros
mon propos c'est que je verrai un assez
beau deuil quelque chose qui ressemble à
une nationalisation de fait du système
électrique voilà je pense que je vais
rester dans la segunda ça veut pas dire
que ils volent n'importe comment et
personnellement je verrai ça demain ses
collègues il faut bien voir que le
dispositif là qui a été mis en oeuvre
pour protéger je l' ai déjà dit je peux
le redire le dispositif qui a été mis en
oeuvre pour faire baisser la facture
d'électricité des français
vous verrez que en espagne et en
grande-bretagne il n'y a pas de
dispositif qui a été mis en oeuvre alors
je ne sais pas si c'est parce que le
gouvernement a déjà considéré qu'il
n'avait pas les moyens de faire ou si
c'est parce qu a pas d'élection dans
trois mois enfin la question se pose et
même si on voulait baisser la facture
des français je vois absolument pas ce
qui nous empêcherait de la faire un
chèque donc on prend les gens qui ont un
d'électricité qui monte mois et un
certain nombre de gens qui n'ont pas de
problèmes de fin de mois qui vivent dans
ce pays ont leur qu'on pense rien du
tout puisque pour acheter tout à fait
les moyens d'encaisser 15 1% de hausse
de la facture d'électricité ayant encore
beaucoup de gens qui ont tout à fait les
moyens d'encaisser 45 % de hausse de la
facture d'électricité c'est pas vraiment
comme si on leur imposait 45 % de hausse
du loyer pas la même chose et puis les
gens qui est sous conditions de
ressources ont fait à chaque un certain
nombre de gens qui eux vont avoir un
premier voilà ça c'est l'annoncé on n'a
pas de pouvoir d'achat on le traite
comme un poème
le dispositif qui a été mis en place par
le gouvernement qui consiste à faire les
poches d'aidé aient fait un truc de
corps de cul c'est la politique de
gribouille
d'abord on va financer les concurrents
en augmentant le volume de la reine ah
oui j'ai oublié de préciser un truc
c'est la réponse je vais rentrer dans
les détails au moment où on a créé la
concurrence entre guillemets dont vous
avez bien compris ce n'est pas une
concurrence non une dépense ddf on a dit
quoi on a dit ces gens là ils vont pas
avoir les moyens de produire leur propre
électricité donc on va forcer et df à
leur vendre à perte car c'est une vente
à perte normalement interdite par la loi
quand il s'agit d'autres supermarchés on
va forcer et df à leur vendre à perte
une partie de l'électricité qu'ils
produisent alors j'insiste sur le fait
que physiquement c'est les mêmes
centrales injectant dans le même réseau
c'est les mêmes électro ddf qui arrive
chez vous mais
conventionnellement on considère qu'il
ya des gens qui vont se servir au
passage et donc on va leur vendre une
partie de la production nucléaire
historique et ça s'appelle la reine le
tarif auquel on enfants ça donc c'est
l'accès réglementé à l'électricité
nucléaire historique ça veut dire qu'en
gros on leur donne est donc dans un
monde concurrentiel
on leur donne une garantie d'achat c'est
quand même beau moi je veux dire que je
suis dans le monde concurrentiel avec
les activités de conseil on n'a jamais
donné garantie d'achat sur quoi que ce
soit il y aurait trop de garanties de
vendre quoi que ce soit
donc on leur donne une garantie d'achat
et c'est cette garantie d'achat qu'on a
augmenté c'est à dire que le volume que
edf est obligé de vendre à perte à
d'autres distributeurs qu'on appelle ses
concurrents et qui en fait sont des
dépendants et bien le gouvernement a
décidé de l'augmenter de 20% sauf qu'ils
se trouvent que ce volume d'électricité
et df l'avait déjà par des volumes
supplémentaires d'électricité qui l'on
se prend sur l'électricité dont edf à la
libre disposition et df l'avait déjà
vendu à d'autres parce que les df vont à
terme l'essentiel de son électricité en
avance on va dire c'est s'alimente à
terme
et donc ça veut dire que edf va devoir
se procurer sur le marché à aujourd'hui
alors j'ai pas regardé aujourd'hui à
l'instant où je vous parle en fait la
dernière fois que j'ai regardé il ya
quelques jours on est quelques jours à
250 300 euros mégawattheure électrique
va donc devoir acheter sur le marché les
mégawattheure à 250 ou 300 euros pour
les revendre à ses concurrents aux
alentours de 46 euros ce qui va lui
coûter quelques milliards bigard
vous n'êtes même pas garanties sur le
fait que les concurrents recevant cette
électricité pas chers vont vouloir
vendre pour pas cher si ça se trouve ils
vont juste sauver leurs fesses et
reconstituer leurs marges et continue à
le vendre l'électricité au même prix
c'est un truc de corps de cul dans
lequel on prend un des concurrents qu'on
continue à appeler service public alors
que normalement dans un marché
concurrentiel vous n'avez pas de service
public au jir - encore une fois 44 étant
un marché concurrentiel personne n'a dit
quart 24,6 le service public du conseil
en stratégie carbone qui se passe ici et
là donc on prend quelqu'un on a dit
maintenant vous allez être concurrents
mais en fait non john concurrents quand
ça vous arrange si vous êtes service
public quand ça nous arrange et donc là
que les services publics donc on va vous
faire les poches pour financer vos
concurrents donc on se retrouve avec
qu'edf qui finance une filiale de total
voilà vous avez compris ce que j'en
pense c'est juste du grand n'importe
quoi et bien évidemment que ce grand
n'importe quoi arrive à trois mois des
élections de 30 personnes et je vais
vous dire je donne pas de consigne de
vote mais j'espère que ça va coûter
quelques voix macron parce que c'est
vraiment trop du n'importe quoi
alors
question suivante
mon astrid c'est en dehors du ppf quelle
est la place de l'hydrogène d'enquêté le
f alors la place de l'hydrogène elle est
non négligeable
dans le pdf mais elle n'est pas dans ce
qui a été évoquée le plus souvent en ce
qui concerne l'hydrogène et puis je vous
annonce
crânement que ça va être la dernière
question parce que il est 8 heures 8
heures bon allez je vais encore aller
jusqu'à 12h15 et puis après on va
s'arrêter là
donc ils rejettent dans pts à la place
mais c'est pas pour faire avant tout des
avions à hydrogène et c'est pas pour
faire avant tout des voitures et des
camions à hydrogène c'est pour faire des
applications industrielles à hydrogène
aujourd'hui on produit de l'hydrogène
dans le monde on en produit même en
france et cet hydrogène et les produits
de la manière suivante il est produit
avec ce qu'on appelle dur formage du
méthane ou dur formage d'autres d'autres
combustibles fossiles le procédé est le
suivant vous prenez un compartiment qui
est étanche à l'air et notamment étanche
à l'oxygène et vous mélangez dans ce
compartiment à combustible fossile c'est
à dire un assemblage de carbone et
d'hydrogène en proportions variables et
de l'eau et de la vapeur d'eau et vous
chauffer à très haute température et
vous avez un réarrangement des atomes à
l'intérieur de cette enceinte qui va
s'opérer la vapeur d'eau pas perdre son
d'oxygène donc vous allez vous retrouver
avec de l'hydrogène dans les
combustibles fossiles cet oxygène va
s'associer au carbone juste au carbone
et l'hydrogène va être libéré de son
côté donc vous allez vous retrouver avec
en entrée de la vapeur d'eau et
du méthane pour prendre l'exemple et en
sortie vous retrouver avec du co2 et
d'hydrogène donc c'est un procédé qui
indépendamment du co2 liées à l'énergie
pour chauffer l'ensemble vous libère du
co2 par réaction chimique vous pouvez
pas y échapper cerberus ire de paris a
changé et aujourd'hui pour faire une
tonne d'hydrogène avec du méthane qui
est le moins carboné des combustibles
fossiles ça vous fait des tonnes de co2
par tonne d'hydrogène si vous utilisez
du charbon c'est plutôt 30
donc en fait les prochaines à quoi sert
l'hydrogène aujourd'hui il sert
majoritairement à deux applications la
première c'est des sulfures et les
carburants mais dans le pdf des
carburants comme dans tout le flanc de
neutralité des carburants fossiles on
n'a quasiment plus la plus infime rit
donc on n'a plus besoin d'une
l'hydrogène pour des sulfures et les
carburants de celui là on n'a pas besoin
de produire
l'autre moitié d'hydrogène sert à faire
des engrais les engrais azotés parce que
les engrais azotés dans regarde t il ya
de la zot est en fait cette phase haute
il arrive sous forme d'ammoniac enfin il
est habité par la molécule d'ammoniac
dans la chili les anglais et l'ammoniac
effet en associant la zot qui vient de
l'air avec l'hydrogène qui vient d'être
dans la production il ya d'être expliqué
donc là 40% de la production d'hydrogène
dans le monde sert à fabriquer de la
média qui l'a fait remarquer il ya
servir pour l'exemple des engrais dans
ptf ont continué à en utiliser même si
on rêve tous une agriculture bio sans
engrais etc il ya aujourd'hui on papa
déplacer le système instantanément 2
10 % bio verts 100 % bio et même si on
était 100% respectueux de
l'environnement s'est pas complètement
con dans un certain nombre de domaines
de continuer à garder les engrais parce
que ça augmente il faut juste le faire
de façon intelligente et ça augmente la
façon dont les laits végétaux produisent
et donc c'est quelque chose qui est
pertinent et voilà ce qu'on vous m'aidez
du fumier c'est un autre entraîneur
l'idée même d'utiliser des engrais n'est
pas nécessairement une mauvaise idée
après faut pas en mettre trop
sérieux sujet le continu avoir besoin de
produire des engrais est donc dans le
pdf ondées carbone cette production
d'hydrogène là et on l'a des carbones
avec électricité décarbonés plus électro
lise parce qu'à une autre manière de
décarbonés sept productions j aimerais
juste après et cet hydrogène décarbonés
sert à produire l'ammoniaque qui va
servir à produire les anglais et puis il
ya un autre hydrogène décarbonés qu'on a
envie de produire c'est pour fabriquer
de l'acier alors certains d'entre vous
si vous avez suivi l'actualité vous avez
peut-être entendu parler d'un gros
investissement que arcelor s'apprête à
faire à dunkerque et c'est un gros
investissement il correspond à un
changement complet de procéder qui va
remplacer les hauts fourneaux dans un
haut fourneau vous mettez un mélange de
minerai de fer quand tu es minerai de
fer c'est de l'oxydé de fer on sait du
fer et de l'oxygène associés c'est de la
rouille en gros un la rouille cet oxyde
de fer et du charbon très purifier qu'on
appelle du coq et vous mettez ça
ensemble dans un haut fourneau et une
partie du charbon va dégager de
l'énergie en brûlant et ça va permettre
à une autre partie du charbon d'aller
manger l'oxygène qui est associé aux
faire et ça va vous faire du co2 donc il
part dans l'atmosphère et ça va vous
laisser le fer pur qui associé à
quelques uns kurt et que vous trouvez
dans le haut fourneau vous fait de la
fonte c'est donc aux fourneaux produit
dû faire avec elle deux implantés et qui
s'appelle de
arcelor en fait le procédé qui va être
mis en oeuvre qui existe déjà en suède à
plus petite échelle et d'un procédé qui
s'appelle de réduction directe et à ce
moment vous allez utiliser soit du
méthane soit dans une version
la plus d'égards donné on va dire de
l'hydrogène donc nous c'est celle d'un
conte préconise pour attaquer
directement l'oxydé de fer et à ce
moment c'est l'hydrogène qui se charge
de retirer l'oxygène à l'oxydé de fer ça
fait le boulot donc pas cartonné et vous
vous retrouvez du faire exactement comme
dans un bouffon enfin c'est pas le même
faire mais pas les mêmes impuretés etc
mais c'est un principe et cet hydrogène
il va donc falloir le faire en grande
quantité des carboni à l'heureux taylor
de grandeur que pour remplacer un haut
fourneau faut un petit réacteur
nucléaire pour produire l'hydrogène qui
va permettre d'attaquer la réduction
directe
mais c'est possible et donc dans le pdf
on a une partie de l'électricité qui
sert de l'elysee décarbonés qui sert à
alimenter des électrolyseurs pour à la
fois faire des engrais et fer de l'acier
si on veut en plus de l'hydrogène que
nous faisons aujourd'hui en faire encore
plus pour ray domicilié en france une
partie des choses que nous importons
actuellement et dans les engrais azotés
aujourd'hui on en importe l'essentiel on
en fait une partie chez nous mais
l'essentiel on importe à ce moment il
faut faire encore plus d'hydrogène est
du reste dans le scénario rte vous avez
un scénario réindustrialisation de la
france dans lequel on a besoin de plus
d'électricité décarbonée car c'est
électricité décarbonés va servir à
remettre en france des processus qui
aujourd'hui sont localisés à l'étranger
avec à l'évidence l'aval de la chaîne de
valeur qui du coup est aussi localisé à
l'étranger donc si on veut relocaliser
en france c'est une bonne idée pour
l'emploi et ce qui est pas une mauvaise
idée pour le carbone est bien à ce
moment il faut qu'on est plus
d'électricité décarbonée et donc pour
l'hydrogène il faut qu'on en est
également plus pour localiser certaines
activités industrielles qu'on peut
opérer avec de l'hydrogène les câbles
donc hydrogène et carbone et il a sa
place par contre il est marginal dans le
transport aérien qui de toute façon lui
mais elle diminue dans le pdf en volume
après coup le trafic baisse
et c'est l'héritage du rapport ce2 le
super héros des carbo voler en 2050 d'un
super héros s'appelle iron et carbo
puisque d'autres écoles qui ont rejoints
et le voleur 2050 et tej et dans le dire
par anticipation le volet transport
aérien du pdf et les auteurs du rapport
avait dit on peut retourner pour être
dans tous les sens et mettre tous les
gaines techniques qu'on veut dès qu'on
regarde ce qui est déployable à
l'échelle dans les fentes ans qui nous
restent n'y a pas moyen de faire
autrement que de baisser le trafic si on
veut respecter la limite enfin si on
veut que le transport aérien après de sa
part dans la limite des 2 faut que ces
trafics
donc de l'hydrogène dans les avions
contrairement à ce que racontent sans
cherche à gagner monsieur le maire
n'aurait pas beaucoup et de l'hydrogène
dans les transporteurs est ce qu on en
met quasiment pas non plus l'hydrogène
peut avoir sa pertinence pour tirer
trois trains voilà mais globalement dans
les transports terrestres l'utilisation
directe de l'électricité décarbonée est
beaucoup plus efficace que l'utilisation
de danger donc voila en gros quel est la
place de l'hydrogène dans le dans le pdf
alors
le nouveau dpe non j'attends qu'on fasse
du bâtiment pour ça
mais nouveau dpe est nouveau et revin ça
va être rigolo
et enfin j'ai vu quelques questions sur
l'économie
demorand fibre
la santé qui est déjà répondu
alors je vais répondre à une question
que je n'ai pas vu mais
que je vais me poser à moi même
qui ai
sur la façon dont on arrive quand même à
crantée quelque chose du ptf juste après
l'élection
on s'est fait à nous mêmes la réflexion
en fait c'est pas l'idée ne vient pas de
moi
un des collaborateurs du site project
que 1 des trucs pour devrait faire en
déclinaison de ce plan de transformation
de l'économie française
c'est les mesures indispensables à
prendre dans les cent jours vous savez
que après l'élection présidentielle
il ya un truc qui s'appelle l'état de
traces dont on est tellement contents
d'avoir élu notre président de président
qu'on se dit quand même à bille ou plats
comme tout va bien et donc on fait la
fiesta pour plus c'est l'été c'est sympa
on va élire notre français de la fin du
printemps en attendant les canicules il
fait beau voilà en bref donc on va
trouver ça très sympa et on a ce qu'on
appelle des cent jours alors ce qu'on se
dit nous c'est que les 100 jours c'est
par construction le moment où un
président ou une présidente a les moyens
en gros peut-être pas de faire ce qu'il
veut avec ses cheveux mais pas loin
c'est à dire que il est dans un contexte
dans lequel il peut assez facilement
prendre rapidement des mesures qui sont
assez impactante est donc ce qu'on a
assez envie de faire j'espère qu'on va
avoir le moyen de le faire dans les
quelques mois qui viennent là est
peut-être qu'on sollicitera certains
d'entre vous si vous êtes shifter c'est
de réfléchir à qu'est ce qu'on pourrait
mettre dans un programme qui est le
programme des cent premiers jours c'est
quoi les mesures opérationnelles qui
nous paraissent totalement cohérente
avec le pcf et si ces mesures sont pas
prises dans les 100 premiers jours c'est
une vraiment en gros la personne qu'on a
élu
et vraiment pas en phase avec nous quoi
le g prendre un exemple de mesure des
100 jours qui en fait était une mesure
du premier jour dans le pacte écologique
de nicolas hulot une des mesures qui
étaient mises en avant c'était d'avoir
un super ministre de l'environnement on
savait que le ministre de
l'environnement soit le numéro deux du
gouvernement alors je ne sais pas avec
le recul du temps si au fond c'était la
bonne ou la mauvaise idée peu importe
c'est pas ça le propos le propos était
de dire que ça c'est typiquement une
mesure des 100 jours parce que votre
gouvernement vous le faites juste après
l'élection et donc c'était une façon de
juger si le pacte écologique avait pris
au sérieux ou pas est-ce qu'il y aurait
ou pas ah super ministre de
l'environnement numéro deux du
gouvernement dans le gouvernement qui a
été constituée et la réponse a été oui
parce que ça c'est quelque chose qui est
facile à constater si oui c'est nous et
c'est alors pas plus tard qu'il ya
quelques jours aussi l'idée n'est pas de
moi j'ai entendu une personne dans une
des enceintes où je bredouille
professionnel qui a dit est ce que le
chief project a prévu de demander que
tous les députés nouvellement entre en
fonction qu'est ce que vous pensez que
c'est même pas prochain qu'est ce que
vous pensez de l'idée que tous les
députés nouvellement entré en fonction
suivent une formation énergie climat
voilà typiquement un exemple qui
pourrait être une mesure des 100 jours
si vous faites pas ça c'est qu'au fond
on continuer à avoir la désinvolture sur
le problème voilà donc il faut qu'on se
creuse un peu la cervelle mais on a
assez envie de faire un truc comme ça
j'espère qu'on y arrivera encore une
fois
s'il le fait c'est pas le problème mais
voilà on se dit que c'est une manière
probablement
très opérationnelle de 30 et la
préoccupation dans le grand t
l'existence de craon telle
l'esprit général de ce qu'on propose
dans la classe politique juste après les
élections c'est d'avoir encore une fois
des mesures qui sont très très concrètes
auxquelles on peut réfléchir et qui vont
nous permettre de juger tout de suite si
on a en face de nous des gens qui ont
pris la mesure du problème et qui ont
vraiment envie de s'en occuper ou si on
est tous dans la continuité de
l'existant et ô ma foi parfois il faudra
attendre comme je l'aï dit au début de
ce monologue avec moi même
que on
écrit ce
qui donne l'occasion de sortir le plan
du tiroir
voilà eh bien écoutez
nous ça nous arrivait au terme de cette
petite session
merci beaucoup
à jo elle qui a organisé ce facebook
live
et puis merci à tous ceux d'entre vous
qui ont attendu jusqu'à maintenant
pour quitter la session
et à tous ceux et toutes celles et tous
ceux qui l'ont regardé voilà j'espère
que je pas trop répondu à côté des
questions et j'espère que je n'ai pas
trop frustré ce qui en avait et qui ne
les ont pas maltraités
et le présente également toutes mes
excuses à toutes les personnes qui ont
posé des questions dans le fil de
discussion mais malheureusement comme
vous l'avez compris j'ai d'abord traité
celles qui avaient déposé avant la
session
et j'ai donné la priorité
à cette date voilà eh bien écoutez bonne
fin soirée et puis à une prochaine façon
dont comme disent tous les bons
animateurs radio au revoir